Act like there is.
I assumed there is always assume.
Whoo.
Merry Christmas ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.
Merry Christmas.
It's fucking on.
You understand me?
It's Christmas Eve.
You thought it was going to be Ho hum.
Fuck you.
Uncle Joey.
Joe Rogan had fucking live Christmas eve
talking about bugs in your house and how
easy it is for the feds.
They don't need a bug your house
anymore.
They just use your phone.
Just turned on my Jamie.
Tell them,
tell them what you were telling me about
that.
Uh,
the airpods Oh yeah.
There's a,
there's a new setting on the,
uh,
a new,
an operating system where your airpods
you turned onto this thing called live.
Listen.
And it's listening to the microphone on
your iphone.
So you can leave your phone in a room,
walk out and you can use.
Just made your own bug.
But that means that anybody that can
then access your phone could probably
also listen if they have access to that.
I don't know how drive already said like
can you talk to anybody that knows
what's possible with electronics that
can already turn your microphone on
anytime they want.
Pro.
When I was a kid,
I grew up in that book making Shit and
there was certain bookmakers that
wouldn't talk in a room that there was a
phone in the room,
smart ones in the seventies.
Not talking on the phone,
but if there was a phone in the room
they would leave the room.
Yeah,
that's nice.
At least super paranoid.
They were 30 years ahead of that time.
Will you remember how they got Vincent
the chin.
They started bugging cars along the way
where he would walk.
He would walk with his bathrobe like he
was crazy and he would give everybody
instructions and he would do it on his
walk so he couldn't get bugged anywhere.
So they started bugging the cars along
his walk route.
That's how they got.
Get you with the mic?
Yeah,
it was a lot of the same microphone.
They usually nfl.
When you hear all those tackles and
grunts in the old days they had a
parabolic mic.
Takes vibrations from glass.
Yeah.
So I could just point this laser at your
glass.
Which speakers on and they'll take
whatever you're saying in a room and
bounce it off the glass.
I've heard it.
There's a fucking ass.
So by now,
which world class they can do what?
They're listening to.
Everything.
Anything and everything.
I in the bathroom on the plane,
you have to assume that watching it,
like I used to go in there and do blast
a coke.
I would always pull my pants down,
go through the whole process.
Like I was shit and that wasn't really
shit and I just always thought it was a
camera there.
Well you'd probably be correct.
I've heard things that are just hard
about vegas in the eighties.
How they had cameras in Vegas in the
eighties.
It was all my vegas and the bathrooms
have cameras.
So as soon as you do a blast,
you come out within 10 minutes of cops
around you.
When did they,
when did the mob like officially get out
of Vegas?
Like with the mob is still in Vegas.
Just short spurts.
It's crazy.
I was in New York last week and I
realized how much construction was going
on
and I thought to myself,
how much of that is the mob still
getting?
They had attacks for years,
two percent.
So it fits a $300,
million dollar job.
Do the math on that.
You make it a big chunk on that
construct.
You know,
trump didn't get rich because the
construction business is huge and you
got to New York,
you know,
uh,
I can't give you accurate numbers
because I don't know the numbers are.
But look what the averages for a square
foot of concrete in New York.
And look what the averages in Iowa.
I was reading something about that.
The square foot of,
to build a building in New York,
same.
The concrete is fucking insane because
so many hands are getting fucking
greased.
You know,
you don't pay a job.
Okay?
So you don't pay.
It's like that one episode of the
Sopranos.
So what I do is break your balls.
You would gc you don't want to pay me my
money.
That's fine.
I sent somebody from the Union and
instead of me doing this,
come on through.
I gotta stop you gotTa.
Take your book.
I got to call the unit to see if you
paid your dues.
We check your tire pressure.
We can help.
Let's the windows on the truck.
Recently you got 30 trucks backed up and
you're not making any money.
That's how they shake you down.
That's the shame then.
Or you paid me.
Okay.
The trucks go through.
Don't worry.
Would sign them.
We don't care who the driver is.
We don't care if it's union or non
union.
It's such a dirty business at that
level.
That's the shade.
Now trump would be the GC on the job.
You pay your job runs smooth,
you don't pay.
So two percent of them went to the mom
that concrete tax.
Then they had like another two percent
right off the top 200 bid rig bedroom
bed rigging.
Where we take,
we give it to Joe Rogan.
No matter what the price is,
we inflate the price.
Even though Jamie comes in $3,000,000
cheaper,
I'm going to give Joe Rogan that three
and two more.
Joe Rogan's going to kick that to me and
we're going to do the job,
but that's $3,000,000
profit.
Plus I'm going to take two percent off
the top of that $3,000,000
a
profit.
You know what I noticed when I was a kid
when I was working construction,
one of the first things I noticed,
it's one of the weird businesses that's
run almost exclusively by men like manly
men,
like the construction guys were burly
dudes with big fucking hands.
They worked hard and they were like,
these were like rough guys,
but they were running a big business.
It's like all these other businesses.
If you think about businesses you think
about like computers,
you don't think about like rugged,
burly guys,
but computers and construction or just
as calm and like everybody needs a
computer.
Everybody needs a house like
constructions everywhere.
It's a gigantic business and it's run at
least in back in when I was working as a
laborer.
It was run by these big savages too.
Fucking big dangerous guys,
but it's gotten more diverse now because
unions have made you hire more women.
When I was no attrition,
like three months and there was a female
supervisor who knew her shit.
A Dad that was electrician when she was
a kid that was fucking day job and men
had a tough time working for.
I clicked with her.
She was easy.
She would leave me the fuck alone.
Sometimes men can't.
They just have a real hard time with a
woman telling me I didn't.
I didn't mind that at all.
I didn't give a fuck.
I liked her.
If someone's great at their job,
they're great at their job.
Just kind of give a fuck what the gender
is.
A weird thing that a lot of guys have,
right?
You know,
female trainer,
that female trainers.
A lot of people don't go for that.
Female Yoel Romero.
One of the best mother fuckers of all
time.
What is she trained them in?
No Man's fit.
Strengthen conditioning.
She was strengthening conditioning.
Training him in this videos,
watching Boston his ass.
Well,
even like super savage know.
Make sure I'm right about that.
Make sure my worried about that because
if it's not well,
it's someone equally savage,
someone who's just fuck this super alpha
mean.
No one's a super alpha like,
well,
when we had them in the podcast I was
looking at,
I'm sitting there,
I was saying this guy has built,
it's not even a real person with 12
hours should get over.
I remember that night we both had spots
the store and I pulled you aside and I
go,
what really think?
What do you really think?
I mean there's this guy,
shoot the people,
or is this something that just think
it's genetic super freak genetic.
Well,
when we went to eat at,
I went to New York last week,
I purposely went to a SAR and Tina,
it's a restaurant North Berg and don't
run by this dude named Jocko Jesus
Christ to spaghetti with a tiny
meatballs.
I couldn't even finish it,
but one of his waiters was a wrestler
and listened to the podcast and he was
saying he wasn't that good.
He was on the bottom floor.
He ate the scraps and he.
But he goes,
yeah,
I know you're well from back there.
Just last week.
Think about the other super athletes
that have come out of Cuba,
but that have gotten into mma and
boxing.
Okay.
Hector Lombard,
dude,
my,
a lot of people,
they might look at Hector lumbar because
of some of his tough fights that he had
in the UFC later in his career.
But if you go back and watch Hector
Lombard Willingness,
rod and shit and bell,
it tore.
Those were probably his prime years.
He was the champion at Belterra.
I mean fucking smashing people.
Smashing people at 185 pounds.
And then he came over to the UFC.
He fought one 85,
but there's a big ass one 80 fives in
the UFC man.
I mean hector is.
What do you think?
He's five sex really?
Not that.
No,
I think he's.
I think he's either my height or I'm
five.
Eight.
He's either my hydro,
he's an inch taller but he's so jacked.
And when he was,
when he was smashing people,
like earlier as career man,
I always wanted to get him in the UFC.
I was like,
this guy needs to come over.
He's,
he's so athletic,
man.
He would,
and he's a judo player.
I mean,
it's,
look how fucking checked hector is.
He's,
you know,
he was a judo player for Cuba,
but I'm telling you meant did,
you could take all the steroids in the
world.
You're not going to move.
Like this guy moves.
Josh lumbar.
Josh Barnett Rather told me that,
uh,
Hector Lombard when he went to the gym
could just do muscle up after muscle up.
Never even trained it before.
It's saw.
Jamie will tell you,
it's fucking hard to do a muscle up.
He just grabs that bar.
He's a super athlete.
He's just had a lot of really,
really rough fights against the best
fighters in the world.
And I,
I really think that some of his best
fights you could say like maybe he was
tested more and I think he certainly was
tested more here in the UFC then it
wasn't belt or certainly the caliber of
competition is far greater.
But I also think fighters have like a
window of opportunity for the most part.
For most of them.
There's exceptions where they can extend
that window,
the the,
the experts seem to think the windows
around nine years.
This is not a number that I invented,
but it's a number that I agree with in
terms of like the best you have,
you might be able to do it for nine
years,
like fate or the longevity of another
running back a street and a half years,
which blew my mind.
That's crazy.
That blew my mind.
I started thinking about it.
I talk about all the greats.
I'd go to a butter.
Oh Campbell,
Jim Brown,
those guys.
I thought about their injuries.
How lucky you have to be.
Okay.
Though.
The UFC is a fighter.
How many people actually did fight in
the UFC for nine years straight so far
out a lot.
There's been quite a few.
A Lot,
but at the same time there's been a lot
of guys that have had great both pension
by the fourth or fifth fight.
They've moved on.
Well,
you know,
everybody's different.
This is the thing.
Everybody's different in terms of their
ability to recuperate.
style.
Like some guys just don't take much
damage,
you know,
something like Ben Aspirin,
perfect example,
never fought in the UFC,
but when you watch him fight in these
other organizations,
thing that's most interesting is that it
doesn't take any damage you could say is
boring if you want to.
I don't think it's boring.
I think it's super high level wrestling
and you need to see how that shit would
fly against the best in the world.
I mean that's why he's here now.
I'm very excited about this,
but he's a perfect example of like he
doesn't have any problems.
That guy has been fighting for a long
time.
You talked to him.
He says lucid as they come.
He's articulate.
He's very smart,
very well educated,
reads books all the time.
He'll send me recommendations for books.
Very,
very interesting guy.
So you've got those guys who like,
he could do it for a long fucking time
because he's not taking a beating when
you start taking a beating man pool.
You know,
some guys,
sometimes guys try to get back in there
too soon and they're still hurting,
you know,
from,
from a fight,
like a really bad knockout or uh,
just sometimes even just getting beaten
up is we're like,
you get,
if you don't get stopped,
like you incur more damage that way,
you know,
for a long ass fight than you would in a
quick Kao,
you know,
like I'm in glory.
You know,
Joseph Valtellina deal,
you know that the zoo could joe,
he was their champion and he won the
title against Mark Dumond after the
fight couldn't fight again because
concussions were so bad.
He couldn't look at a,
the light from a,
an iphone charger,
like a laptop charger.
That little light from that thing would
be blinding to him.
He had to be like in a dark room for
three weeks.
Cbd Oil brought them out of it.
When I think of fighters and what
happens during a fight,
I go back all the way to Bernard Hopkins
against Felix trailer that because you
brought it up to my attention,
I never even knew about that world.
He never came back,
said,
who's the guy that went the distance
that's known?
Bella coola fights out of GSPS.
Can't really.
Tough guy went five rounds with fucking
what's his name is Rory Macdonald.
Rory Rory.
After that fight that he had,
he was never really the same title.
Robbie lawler for Robbie lawler fight.
Fight to affect you in different ways to
beat and you take.
Affects you in different ways.
I want to see what the kid that Edson
Barboza fights with next time he comes
out,
he took a ferocious beating against at
Edgar Edson,
that last fight before allocated the and
Kevin Lee.
See,
but rory,
I got to disagree because after that
fight,
he looked fucking phenomenal in beltour
and his first wife.
Who was his first fight and belt,
or was it Paul Daley?
He fought.
Um,
but then the next fight,
he didn't mean he was a beast though.
Dude knew him as a monster man.
Douglas Lema is a fucking straight up
killer.
You know the comedy sometimes.
Was it Paul Daley?
So he manhandled Paul daily.
It's very smart fight because he fought
really well on his feet first.
Threatened daily,
little bit on his feet and then took him
down,
dominated them on the ground and it was
uh,
it was,
it was a very impressive win.
But then he fought.
See,
fighting Musashi I think was probably
not the,
but you know,
you never know.
You know,
you got to test yourself.
There's only one way to do that.
And he knows better than anybody.
I mean the guys in it to test himself
now he knows that he can't beat massage
at least at this point in his life.
But he's a smart kid.
Then he's,
he's an animal to.
I mean,
that guy is.
So I will not say that.
I just thought that a lot of times after
battles,
people don't come back
the same.
I agree on some of them,
but I don't,
I don't agree with him.
The guy from Texas that took GSP to the
zoo and he never came.
You know,
some people give it all.
You got to give it all.
You got moment.
It's either react after that,
uh,
what's going to happen?
How is Kevin legally to come back?
So I quit that.
You always have those questions,
which is a great fight,
by the way.
Amazing though.
The fight I was most excited about this
weekend was Michael Gac.
Carlos conduit,
right.
It's a good buddy would call those of,
you know,
call of little.
Been around for a long fucking time,
just name is conduct,
but because he knows I'm his brother and
I'm one of the biggest fans and the
Mafia.
I'd hire him from the UFC a long time
ago because he's an assassin.
He's realized John,
when you just give him a gun with a
silencer,
a pencil,
let him do the rest.
Go down and you could switch his mind
quick with $600,000
a week.
I want to say that his UFC was his debut
against Brock Larson.
Was that it was as debut.
Was that in the WEC?
I feel like that was in the WEC.
I feel like his debut was against um,
Shit.
Uh,
was it Jake Martin?
Kampmann was his debut in Nashville,
a natural birth or own burger.
Was that.
Oh,
that was jake ellenberger his first
fight in UFC.
Yeah,
to Jake ellenberger was another one.
Met Super fucking dangerous for a long
time,
man.
You ever see before he fought in the
UFC,
when he knocked out Palae with one punch
to beat in my office about three weeks
ago he came into my office and he's the
nicest guy.
I heard you got a gallon.
Dosed him up.
I gave a bunch of this shit that was 31
percent.
He couldn't answer questions dog.
It was like,
fuck it.
He's the best.
The poor bastard.
He didn't know how to drive home folks.
Boom.
Data was not around.
Rocco was broke.
This system for a week.
If you think brock lesnar system
disappeared,
the fucking system.
Whatever.
Oh my God.
What?
Jake ellenberger.
We took them deep.
I haven't seen it,
but I've heard.
He told me.
He goes,
you know,
I don't smoke them.
I didn't do a little bungalow and I
asked him a question after that.
He was just frustrated.
I love that he's coming back to redeem
himself.
Sad.
He's never smoked and again,
but that was toughest battle.
Yeah,
you can't.
That's too much.
That's a three foot bong.
Well,
not only that,
joey,
for most people that don't do podcasts
all the time,
getting on your podcast,
it's a mind fuck because it was like,
I can't believe I'm here.
I'm sitting here with Uncle Joey.
Holy Shit.
And then boom,
that 30,
how many percent?
Thirty one.
That's so high.
This is alien.
Whoa.
Gee,
this is in,
in.
Just as a.
for people that don't know the numbers,
let's find out what the numbers actually
are.
Like.
What was.
What percentage thc was marijuana in the
19 seventies?
I want to say it was like eight to 10
probably.
I'm just guessing.
It's so funny how.
Okay.
I grew up in New York,
New Jersey,
so I would go to Harlem and what we had
available to us was a Panama Red
Colombian gold.
I could be worse.
I could be running other names.
And then you had from Jamaica,
you had this week called lamins bread
and then suddenly the eighties,
the green weed came along and they
called it since Amelia,
so I was copying a hundred and 48th
street.
Then he will either sell your chocolate
pie,
which is lamb's bread,
or he would sell you a sense of me,
yet he would put them together and call
it the master mix and then if you bought
10 bags of the master mix,
she got one for free,
gave you a punch card.
This is why not go a real punch.
Nineteen 83 slash 83.
The guy was in the middle of the corner
hanging out and the funny thing was I
went back in [inaudible] 85 and he
looked me straight in the face and he
was like,
ain't no motherfucking weed on this
block.
No more dog crap.
Like it had just converted to crack,
but this is why.
Watch him.
I told you that watching Narcos,
Mexico,
those first two episodes are so
important because it's like,
it's like some comments when you watch a
TV show,
it's really hard to believe that one day
some Spanish guy that couldn't even
speak English said,
hey,
there's not three cameras here.
His name was fucking loose.
Desi Arnaz.
Desi Arnaz invented that.
The three camera shoot.
You know that.
That's hilarious.
That desi loop production to all that
shit.
He's the one that said,
took her eight white people sitting
around,
get two more cameras.
Let's go underlay.
Oh,
the guy that did the principle Guy
Narcos to share is a character who grew
weed in the desert.
I want you to think about that,
and I've never been even thought of
before,
but by doing that,
I don't know the science,
so please Joe Rogan.
People don't torture me.
He eliminated the male plant to make the
female stronger.
The only way you could grow that isn't
the desert,
so he found water in the desert.
Why is it the only way you can go grow
in the desert?
It's something about the climate to to
roof so that it's like the immaculate
conception when you get pregnant without
getting pregnant,
so you eliminate the male plants or
something.
I do not know this information and we
have to hide this information from women
so there's no seeds and the reefer get
stronger.
That started in the eighties.
That's why if you watched Narcos,
Mexico,
it shows you how that whole thing
started
and they were pumping 15 metric tons a
year into the United States with this
shit green.
We'd became Mexican.
Green Weed was when we started smoking.
I got to say that average was maybe 15.
Then like the strongest and then there's
weeds down 21 percent.
They take me to the fucking mountain,
but that 28 or above and a bong you'd
do.
You started in your mum when you're
fucking can't focus.
I like that feeling.
At night when I listened to music,
I'm a big music will not.
I called you.
It was like October third and I was
going to call you to tell you that I
love to participate in so broad,
but because of my love for music,
it's not going to happen because my
thing is to go home at night or
sometimes I go to the office.
Like I told you my house is dead at 20
to nine or 8:30
and my wife's in bed 10 minutes later.
Some nights I don't have a spa podcast.
I just go to my office.
I bring a notebook on my ipad,
my get stoned,
and I put it on the album.
I go down the album road and I just get
fucked up and listen to that music.
I love it.
That's my hobby and once a week I go to
the album store and buying a while.
New Vinyl album.
Lately I would now that led Zepplin to
road.
That's one of the greatest,
dirtiest filthiest opens up with a whole
lot of love.
It's just dirty lemon song and then the
heartbreak at.
It's just dirty and then I've been
listening to fucking physical graffiti.
I love going into those foxholes way
that knightstone
yeah,
there's something about that music.
They.
They were the first drug culture music
in America,
right?
If you think about it,
like Zeppelin and pink floyd showed up,
but they went to India.
They grew long hand.
They came back with those four items.
Then there was rumors of acid.
If you listen to the one robotic,
it revolve.
One of those John Lennon spreads acid
bond that was there.
I mean there's A.
There's a lot of musicians from that era
that are great,
that aren't associated with drugs,
but if you think of Hendrix,
if you think of.
I mean Hendrix was always associated
with drugs.
Janis Joplin always associated with
drugs,
you know,
good or bad.
It's.
It's very interesting.
The sound is so.
It lasts like it's so relevant.
If you listen to some Zeplin today,
it's still so God damn good.
They were so good.
Solon Zeplin
tool called bring it on home at the end
he comes out like with a harmonica slow
than Jimmy page kicks in with the
guitar.
You're not stopped.
Like psyche.
Like I should jump out a window like led
Zepplin too.
There's a couple of albums.
I got that office that I put on such a
part of my childhood.
I think about my mom coming into the
room saying yelling lower that fucking
devil music saying weight bias.
I mostly got bar on it and I would blast
it at fucking six.
No morning.
Oh,
the neighbors next door with Jehovah
witnesses and he would knock on my door.
You have to please lower your music.
I never loaded.
Lowered it.
At that age I had a fissure stereo.
Okay.
And I already knew not to get
components.
Like I was already hit.
Like I never bought the album with the
eight track and the cassette.
Fuck you.
I bought an amp and I bought on a
cassette deck and I had a turntable and
I would fucking blasted.
I don't know where I got the speakers
from.
I bought them.
They fell off a truck.
I love music.
Loud my store every time till this day,
every time led zepplins final album
comes out.
I'm truly outdoor comes on the radio or
something.
I think of my mother banging on the door
for freshman year going if I got a knock
on this door one more time.
I'm throwing that out the window like
seven in the morning.
How does that full fucking speed.
Rolling.
Joining,
getting ready to walk up the hill.
Smoking and joy.
I wouldn't smoke at the house.
Nothing like that.
She had no idea.
We play an album albums,
the record player.
Fuck,
I still did you have a good needle?
Memory?
We'd go over to houses,
they had a special needle.
Where'd you go to the NATO?
I just went and got new needles.
I had to order them online.
Fucking impressive guy and I got fucking
cool looking needle.
I still had.
I had a friend that had a reel to reel
Jimmy.
I had a record player in my house for
sure.
Wow.
You gotta reel to reel.
A friend of mine had a real reel in high
school.
Oh my God.
And the sound he bought the speakers and
everything.
He was a sound.
You could hear like the musician pulling
away from the microphone.
Like was that good?
So when he's playing this reel to reel,
got like a,
like a projector screen type deal?
No,
he had a room like this and uh,
he had a shelf and on the shelf he had
speakers and he had a real real,
I think I've connected and it will have
two or three hours of music on it.
So whenever he would have a party,
he would just put on the reel to reel.
At that time.
That was the threat that it's going to
reel to reel.
That's projector,
right?
It's going to reel to reel.
That's the new threat.
That's never made it.
And then it went from,
it went from albums to cassettes to
fucking cds.
So if you put something through that you
would have to Kinda like do it like you
were working in the projection room.
You take the magnetic from one of them
and it works almost.
It's just really large cassette tape
player.
How he put the music on that.
I forget how he put the music on that.
Could you buy music?
Ah,
I think so.
It is recording
but not ness to it looks like.
So you could have recorded something on
there if you had a cable to plug it into
it.
I forget how many copies.
Uh,
the same way you'd put your original
would be like on the left you tend to
feed it.
You did it.
You'd need a copier.
You couldn't do it with this machine
probably,
but that the same way people did with
VCR copies back in the early eighties,
you know,
tape to tape.
You'd find the same thing,
how it would degrade each generation.
You get forms for your friend and it was
like someone threw mud in your eyes.
He tried to watch it.
The fuck is happening on the screen
because it was so many generations of
copied.
Do you remember when porn was wife's
like this?
I don't remember,
but I heard about it and I remember that
movie about the dude from Hogan's
heroes.
That was a,
uh,
he,
he was on Hogan's heroes and after
hoping his heroes,
he just went around making his own
homemade porn and he,
you know,
he had one of these kinds of things.
When the home projector type deals,
porn came in those days.
If you went to the back of a dirty
magazine,
playboy and Penthouse,
but anything else,
they would actually send you a projector
with three movies for say 14,
95.
There was a low end project.
They're probably going to work 10 times,
but at least you got to watch porn and
they'd send you a reel to reel.
That was so bad.
Porn was so bad and I still remember a
story with me and my friends chipping in
and getting the fucking reel to reel
with the thing and plugging it into the
wall and putting sheets on the windows
and it was just horrible,
horrible born white chicks.
They would find them off the streets.
Flapjack Teddy's somebody turned
cigarettes off on a chest and this chick
was half on drugs and she had a suck the
guy's Dick in the most vivid picture of
members.
When she took the mayonnaise with the
bread,
like she was sucking this guy's Dick.
The guy's Dick had been beat up and she
took mayonnaise.
Miracle Whip.
That's why I never liked miracle whip.
She put it on the bread and made a Dick
Sandwiches.
It was dick and it was like me and three
other 12 year olds,
dog.
We almost had a heart attack.
You understand me?
Like our heads blew up.
I tell him who wants this fucking
project?
No,
no,
no.
It was a cheap,
cheap,
cheap little project.
The you had to put a sheet up on the
wall and use it as a screen.
You had a fucking shade up all your
windows and the addict,
because I used to do it in my attic as
my mother wasn't home,
so I will let the first viewing party we
had was in my attic.
You had to send the money on and to send
the dollar 95 for shipping and handling
has an h and then they will take six
weeks to delivery so you would just sit
and you couldn't send it to your house,
so I would have to send it to Rogan's
house because I knew his mother and his
grandmother worked all day so they'll
never be home,
so they would just drop the package off
in front of the house.
If one of our mothers found that
baggage,
we'd be dead.
We'd be fucking dead.
Can You Imagine Your Mother Checkmate
with Miracle Whip on a piece of bread
and eats into the fucking your deck with
you?
Think moms today probably wouldn't even
flinch.
What if,
what if they found their kid with
something like that and his complaint
and fucking kidding me.
Every mom.
The edit.
You talked to any mom or a 15 year old
and go,
do you think your son's getting late?
He's like,
stop it.
I don't want to hear that.
It's true.
No,
mom wants to hear this.
I'm getting laid.
The first girl you brought over the
house actually bothered your mother.
Oh,
I'm sure.
The first two girls you brought loom
actually bothered an irritated the Shit
Outta your mother.
It took your mom awhile because you're
always going to be that little boy.
I can't imagine him getting his dick
suck.
He just.
I just put diapers on 10 years ago.
You know what else they worried about?
They're worried about you getting so
many pregnant because you're so stupid
when you're 15,
16,
17.
You guys are just doing stupid shit.
You know?
You don't really know how to pull out
that good.
How good are you at that?
Very good.
When you were that young,
I mean it's.
Your parents are worried about you doing
something dumb.
Your parents worried about you.
Getting pregnant,
but they also don't want you having sex.
I had the skinny girl friend,
like I always had girls that were
friends and then after the girls leave,
my mom would pull me aside and said,
what's going on?
I go,
nothing.
She's just a friend and I would have
stayed out of the house.
I can't believe it.
You know,
they were friends,
but that was just one skinny girl.
But I used to bring home in the seventh
grade and my mother caught us one
afternoon.
She called US making out.
So she asked me as a man.
She goes from now on,
do me a fucking favor.
If she's here and I'm downstairs,
just leave the door open.
My mom was one of those dog.
She was one of those.
Just do me a favor just from the Middle
East when I leave and lock the door.
But if I'm here,
just leave the door open and I would
leave it open the foot and then try to
eight inches,
six inches and she would have to come up
and say,
I'll tell you with the fucking door open
and then you,
you're an animal at that age.
So at that age you for how we talked to
him yet because all I was doing was dry
humping this girl.
That's all I was doing.
We weren't having sex.
I think I sent the one time we weren't
having sex,
we were just making out dry humping.
But one day I had my mom had the bar
stool and she would just fucking come
home in the afternoon to see if I was at
this broad and one dad in here and she
brought one up,
friends up.
One of her friends were there and I've
been there just swap and split with the
chip.
But I hear something on the wall.
Something is going on.
But I kept dry humping.
We had earth,
wind and fire.
Can I love great fucking arm off.
That's the way of the world.
I'm driving them in this check that you
know,
son,
I hear a lot of slip and the guy starts
yelling and I ran downstairs and there
was one of my mother's friends.
He used to be a bookie at my mother's
boss,
so my mother goes,
I gotta get to the bottom of this.
I got to know what this kid's getting
late.
So he volunteers at the ladder,
at the side of the house to see if I'm
getting laid to look in the window.
I had an air conditioner with a curtain.
He could never see it anyway,
but this girl pissed off my mom fie
years.
This went on for about a year and then I
started taking his shirt off and suck in
attendance and my dad came home when
they caught him in a closet and that was
the end.
And then my mom would give me shit for a
little while.
I got to be 12,
13.
I'm in the sixth grade.
Me and this girl would watch the
osbournes on Friday and Saturday.
Donny and Marie and I would get pissed
off because she had a crush on fucking
Donnie.
You're a kid and then one day,
but then we figured out,
fuck,
if they're gonna,
watch this after three,
why don't we play Hooky from 12 to
three?
We could dry drive for three hours and
nobody will know your grandmother works.
My mother is definitely not coming home.
So we used to play hooky and one day
they caught us and her and I had like,
there was 20 feet between us and a fence
that parents had a house right behind
mine and my mom went into the backyard
like the fuck in Spanish from and that
she is and studied yelling.
Your daughter's a hole over here every
day.
I don't know what they do in that room.
I hope she's not sucking his dick.
My daughter was just.
My son was a regular little boy until
your daughter took over and I knew I
used to walk home and I remember walking
the house and the mom was like,
I need a second.
Your mom's out there yelling horrible
things about my daughter called the
orange.
Wow.
I had to go home and tell my Mama what's
up with that.
She's a fucking whore for the job.
My mom career woman drove by that,
but I got a girlfriend and no more
problems after that.
It was just this skinny chick that drove
my motherfucking crazy.
Hey,
they made you bad.
Mean imagine you have a little boy and
you take them to the park and he's a
cute little fella and he runs and he
stumbles and falls down and cries and
you pick them up and he hugs you and you
love him and you're like,
it's okay.
You just scrape your knee.
It's okay,
and he's crying and crying.
You feel so bad.
You get them a bandaid and give him a
kiss and talk to them and hang out with
them.
Then he goes to sleep and you sit there
and you look at him sleep and you think
about how precious he is,
a sort of life form you you're entrusted
with.
You've got 15 years later,
someone sucking his dick,
some dirty little girl down the block.
God dammit.
Look at that.
Now he's all endure all the time and
obsessed.
Whether it's driving you nuts.
How's your baby?
Your baby stuck with some tramp tramp.
You have daughters,
you US dollars,
which is a.
that's a hell on earth.
Having a daughter.
It's fun now.
It's cute.
She puts costume.
She loves daddy.
She watches TV,
but there's an accommodation once to go
to the mall with her friends.
Yeah,
the letter you have to worry and it's
not the same world.
So you know,
the world is not the same now and it's
not going to be the same when they're
older.
It's getting weirder and weirder.
You know,
people getting,
you know,
we're talking earlier about bugs and
searches and people being will turn your
microphones on.
It has a matter of time before there's
no privacy.
Whether it's 50 years,
whether it's 100 years.
And I mean I think there's gonna be no
privacy with anything.
I don't think with your thoughts.
I think we're going to.
The next thing after cell phones is
going to be something that allows us to
communicate way easier.
They're gonna.
There's gonna within the next 50 years.
They're going to come up with some way
where we're going to be all communicate
through what device.
It's going to be better than just
talking.
We're going to.
We're going to share thoughts.
It's going to get really fucking
strange.
I'm a hundred percent convinced.
I think all of this stuff is just
getting everything accelerates,
right?
It used to be really hard to get ahold
of somebody and now it's really easy to
get ahold of somebody and now you're
gonna.
People figured out ways to turn people's
microphones on and record them and
people are putting tape over their
webcam.
I want you to look at while I'm checking
off like did they think someone's gonna?
Look through it from the other side.
They probably can.
It's going to be a matter of time before
everybody can with everybody,
with everything you do is going to be.
There's going to be all,
all information available to everybody.
This is going to happen.
We're so far away from where we were in
the seventies so far away,
so far away,
so far away and that was our lifetime.
We can remember the seventies,
you know,
1973.
I was six years old.
Okay.
I remember that.
I remember,
I remember the Vietnam War.
I remember when the war ended thinking
when I was a little kid.
This is great that the war is over
because now they know that war is bad
and they won't do any war anymore.
The war is over.
It's gone.
And then when the war started up again
when I was,
I think I was 21,
when Desert Storm kicked in,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
They're doing it again.
Me and my friend Jimmy,
to tell you we had an apartment in.
Think it was fucking.
Where were we?
Malden or some shit.
I forget where the fuck we were.
Wall Fan.
That's where we were,
were in Waltham.
We had this fucking apartment and uh,
we were sitting there on TV,
which is sitting in front of the living
room.
I didn't think we had a couch.
We just sit in there in the living room
watching these fucking missiles flying
through the air and I'll never forget.
He goes,
buddy looks like we're at war.
And I was like,
what?
How?
They were both sitting there going,
what the fuck we're at war.
I thought we didn't do that anymore.
I remember that.
I remember that whole that time when,
when that was how you got information
from the TV a so far removed from today.
Today,
everything that happens all the time is
coming at Ya a hundred miles an hour
from every direction.
There's just too much.
You have to control it.
You still have to have a life.
You still,
you know,
I don't have facebook on my phone,
I have my email account.
I try to keep twitter off my phone when
I go on the road.
The IPAD has no twitter,
no facebook,
it's too much.
It's too much to fee.
Is that who we are?
And if you haven't caught that by now,
you're not catching this.
You know,
I helped open up my twitter on a
Saturday just to see who's tweet.
Thinking to myself,
what are you doing with your fucking
life that you had tweeted on Friday and
fucking Saturday and Sunday.
You know,
it becomes a little game.
It's a little game.
You have to give it a breather.
You have to you.
It's too much news coming at you from
two.
Oh,
two on your satellite disk.
It's,
it's too much news from sports to World
News.
You Got Hln,
CNN,
and then espn all of the fucking row.
It's too fast.
It's too quick.
Last week when I was home,
my buddy,
uh,
as a cab driver,
I took six.
Uber's on Monday in New York.
Tuesday I just wanted to take a cab.
I took my wife to get some real pizza.
Roma Pizza.
The guy that was making pizza that was
still there when I was a kid.
I drove by one day and I go,
he's still in there,
so we took a fucking cab on the cat and
this guy that drove me as a friend of
mine,
we grew up together since we were 12 and
we were talking.
I go,
that's the fast first gas station that
robbed.
And then it goes.
Remember when we were 12?
We were walking home and I,
Freddy Prince got killed.
Wow.
Freddy Prince.
That killed himself the name before.
We didn't find out till that 6:00
news.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That was the gap in time.
So you got your news and even though
that was New York was the city capital
who watch tv in the morning,
maybe they mentioned it in the morning
reports out of La.
Freddy in hospital.
Yeah.
But you never saw it,
but no,
I,
I remember us being out and them saying
Freddy Prince died.
He shot himself last night and I still
remember how cold it was,
January or February.
It was fucking freezing,
but we were walking home.
We were 12 and what do we see in front
of this guy?
Passed out drunk.
Just hammered drunk on the floor.
So we're like,
let's get the money out of his pocket.
You take the bottle.
It was like a bottle of dewar's or
whatever.
So our plan was to take a bottle and
shake a bum.
What?
What's it called?
You roll a bum and we put our hands in
his pocket.
He grabbed one of us like Gary.
So next they don't have to realize it's
just started kicking him like we must
have kicked the maybe two times and we
ran away the bottle.
You gotta be chases Jesus shirt,
pet cemetery.
So we lost them.
Like you get all those weird things like
that's what I associate with like Freddy
Shadow himself at night.
They must have mentioned it in the
morning.
I was too busy going to school and it
wasn't confirmed until the next day.
That's how slow new was.
Now you're getting news.
You get hit with 200 stories in 10
minutes.
What happened in prints?
What trump decided what the UFC is
doing.
What fucking Penny Marshall died.
You get natural all day.
You really can't control it.
Take your child.
You've watched these two young girls
grow up.
Do you ever have days where you take
them somewhere?
Disney and it's so much information
they've got to go back.
I'm thinking that yeah,
it happens to us.
Yeah.
That's got to be happening to us.
Well for sure it's wearing you out and
it's a lot of it is really negative too.
That's another part of the problem is
what's interesting to people is what's
dangerous and there's not much
dangerous,
so what's interesting to people becomes
being negative,
being nasty about something,
complaining about things,
bitching about that,
starting starting twitter fights like
people
enjoy doing it,
they're like they're looking for for
battles.
I wished there was a way where people
could choose to only engage online
without insulting people and just trying
to get a rise out of people like a troll
free way of interacting,
but it's never going to happen.
So you got to kind of accept what it is
is.
So if you accept what it is,
you should be very wary about entering
to anything.
We're 60 percent of what you're
experiencing is negative.
Anything,
anything in life where you're looking at
60 percent negative,
you don't have to do it.
Like being informed is one thing,
but that's more than just being informed
because how much of that information is
even valuable to you?
A lot of it is just getting soaked,
soaked into these fucking horrible
stories.
You know what I mean?
I,
I went down a rabbit hole the other day
reading about this,
uh,
these Scandinavian tourists that got
beheaded in Morocco,
in the mountains.
These girls were hitchhiking and went,
it's fucking horrible.
It's horrible,
horrible stuff.
Matt.
And then I watched a video of it.
It's horrible
showroom.
And you know,
I love your room.
Number one,
logo headshot going to Morocco.
Mind your fucking business.
Girls apparently did this all over the
world.
Either you're talking about a guy that
fucking went somewhere and tried to
convert a tribe.
They showed up with a fucking Bible.
You Mind Your Business?
So I send the fucking Bible via mail and
do the best you can.
Some people will want to put themselves
in danger's way.
They fucking hate that shit.
I fucking hate all that shit.
I like controlling my situation.
I really do.
I don't want to sound shallow.
I would love to be able to have a
passport and go to China and go to
Italy,
but I'm not going nowhere.
Whether there's nothing fucking crazy
going on.
I don't need that in my life,
right?
I don't want to hear a bomb when I'm
fucking sleep and when I'm in Israel,
talked to her the other day.
You gave bombs going off telling me
jokes on the phone.
You can hear a bomb going off and shit,
I don't need that.
I don't need none of that shit that's
putting yourself in harm's way,
you know,
and I appreciate the balls.
I appreciate them.
Balls.
Are you climbing a mountain agero?
I appreciate all that stuff,
but it's not in my percentage graph.
I believe in percentages.
You understand me?
I get it.
So it's just the other night I read to.
I get high at night guys.
I do comedy and to come down I smoke 55
fucking Bong hits.
Sometimes you don't have to say a joke
on twitter.
The joke is written when you read it as
a human being,
you're saying this is a very interesting
article,
but at the same time it does have
elements of humor in it.
There's an article of a hot chick and
then it says,
mother goes to court to complain about a
teacher who fucked a 15 year old kid
because his life has changed,
has never been the same since she fucked
him.
Show it as the kid's never going to get
his dick.
Suck like that again.
Can you imagine getting a teacher to
blow your horn when you're in high
school?
One of those dirty teeth.
See a picture of a Joe Rogan with a
fresh and a boat with a bikini.
Now you take this chick to the prom and
she sucking your Dick,
Ryan.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
I've never done this before.
You know what I'm saying?
Like reluctant.
His life is changed.
It's a joke dog.
I got to attack the two days and I
didn't reattach people.
I turned it around on them.
I called them love.
Listen,
Merry Christmas,
and they had no where to go.
It's so funny that you could get caught
in that.
They forget what Comedians we are a a
tube,
a tube that transport something really
ugly into something that's still ugly,
but a little bit of funny to it.
I cracked a joke when I found my mother
dead on the floor to myself,
which I knew she was never going to
know.
I got left back because I got back,
but I never told and it was coming on a
year.
I had a tower.
She was.
She kept asking me,
have you chosen to college yet?
And I'm a sophomore year for three
years.
I ran the scam of my mother.
I had that.
I tell her she thought I was a junior.
I was a sophomore,
so as soon as I made that turn,
I picked her up.
I saw arm was purple.
I kissed her forehead,
but I remember popping up and going.
I knew this wasn't going to have a fund
that I before.
I dial nine one one.
So if I dropped humor at that situation,
that's how I fucking handle myself.
Well,
that's how you.
Yeah,
you have to drop you.
I will drop a bomb on you at a funeral.
Joe Rogan,
I will drop a bomb on you and that you
will look at me and go,
God is the balls on you,
but thank God you came every time with
Dave always said,
when Phil Hartman didn't win an emmy,
what we were all in the audience,
right?
Went there to honor him because he got
nominated and the dude from Frasier,
one day he turns to me and Steven.
Rudy goes,
what the hell did you have to do to win?
He goes,
he got shot for fuck sake.
Foley's a funny way.
If I really is,
people have no idea.
When I see people arguing now like now
as a 55 year old,
you look at it and you go,
I threw away 20 years of my life.
Are you with people that I had no reason
to argue with them for it's not even
worth it.
If they played the tape back,
you'd laugh at yourself and feel
horrible.
You look at Shit now you go,
what is.
How does this even affect your life?
I want so CNN,
like when you're in a hotel room on the
weekends,
you go down and CNN or see hsbc
political pipe hole.
Oh,
I love those for six minutes to see
people get fired up and they attack each
other and you know,
and everybody's fucking bullshit,
but you sit there and you go,
what is the big fucking deal?
No matter if hit what makes a comeback
and he's president.
You all got to get up and go to work.
Every morning is giving your money
anymore.
It's not like somebody giving you money
or they're pointing you in the house for
free.
If it Dell resurfaces from the grave,
he is the president.
You still gotta work.
You still gotta build houses.
You still got announce the UFC.
You're still so what?
What?
How much does it really affect you at?
At least that's how I've always thought.
The problem with all these shows is all
of them,
whether it's CNN or Fox News,
is that they're leaning.
They're leaning in somewhere.
The lean in one there,
they're telling you about the news,
but they're leaning on it in a way.
They're not just simply recording the
facts,
especially Fox News.
Right?
They lean like,
I don't know.
I don't know what you guys are talking
about when you say that,
but I will tell you.
Yeah.
When people talk to me about left and
right,
I have no idea because I don't even know
where I stand on most issues,
but guess what I did see in New York and
New Jersey last week take a guess of
what I did not see homeless people
really like because it's so cold.
I was homeless for Nineteen Days in New
York in December,
December twelfth through the 30.
First I got a hotel room maybe 50
percent of the time,
but besides that I was homeless at one
time in 1984.
Usually I ask people and you say,
hmm.
I saw very small sections of not
encampments,
but homeless present percentage was
smaller,
so I asked somebody what that is.
How come I have somebody homeless people
out here?
They said it's was because they're
liberals.
I didn't fucking know that's what
liberal was.
I had no idea.
I mean,
California is liberal.
I just try to be a human being.
I don't know.
That doesn't make sense.
It's like,
what does that mean?
Then what were the homeless go?
Do we make more of them out here?
Is that what he's saying?
Do you allow it to Las Vegas?
He was telling me that Las Vegas ships,
they're homeless,
scares them a bus to California and I
went to the ship.
I feel like the shipping is about
busting people like Alaska for a little
while or something like that.
A couple of years.
You saw the TV show wild wild country.
Do you see that?
It's on the niche is that I said rag
niche,
a cult from
Oregon and uh,
one of the things they did to,
they took over the town,
all heard about it and watched it.
Homeless people in buses and then how
all those people vote.
And then they took over the fucking
town.
They're like developed a real town.
And then they took over this one area of
bust out how America moves.
It's homelessness.
Whoa.
Each year us city gives thousands of
homeless people one way bus tickets out
of town and 18 month Nathan nationwide
investigation,
but the Guardian reveals for the first
time what really happens at journey's
end.
Whoa.
That sounds like a m night Shyamalan
movie,
right?
That kill a bunch of homeless people
like Satan's involved.
It's like they just move them away.
What do they sit where they ship them?
I don't know.
Looks like they're throwing them down in
Miami and in La.
Well,
lives in Colorado.
In Colorado.
People would.
The homeless people would commit crimes.
They figured out what crimes they would
get 60 days for and they would commit
that crime,
plead guilty.
Do the 60 days just to get a little
winter because in those days boulder
would give you tobacco.
You were allowed.
They will give you tobacco,
but you had a role in that Boulder
County jail in 1991,
Boulder County jail and some other jail.
We're voted number one and two jails in
the country.
Wow.
That people would want to go to those
jails and bold the built the new jail
and it became fucking commy this land
like Aspen Cardenas land.
Yeah,
like no cigarettes.
Everybody had to wear uniforms no more.
Staying up till two in the morning when
I was wrong the other way.
Boulder County jail the way.
What was the good way?
Oh,
county jail was a paradise,
but what was wrong with that?
It got out.
It got out that it was too nice.
So like I'm telling you,
homeless people will commit a crime to
do 60 days.
Can I ask you something?
As a person who's been in jail that
would it motivate you more?
This is an honest question.
Would it motivate you more if you were
in jail and it was nice and comfortable
in there and you got to relax and calm
down or would it motivate you more if
they brought you into some communist
type jail as you described it with
everybody.
I'd wear uniforms there.
No cigarettes.
There was no fun.
They limited your outside time,
but when I did them both,
what would.
What I think is a person who's been
through what would be most effective in
rehabilitating you?
I mean,
that's the idea,
right and rehabilitative right now.
You said to me,
you gotta stay this fucking building for
six months.
This is going to be a jail.
Is like Pablo jail.
It's still jail.
I want you to remember that you can not
leave the building for six months.
I will let you go out to the front and a
cage one hour a day,
but you got to figure out what you're
going to do in a for 12 months.
It's a cage.
Yes.
I have more options here.
I can lift weights.
I do different parts of my body.
I could shoot pool,
blah,
blah.
Boulder was very simple.
Boldly got locked up.
They gave you lemons.
You either took them away.
Not only at my own clothes.
So you called home at lunchtime.
Joe Rogan brought me my jeans,
my sneakers,
my tee shirts.
I'm wearing my own clothes.
So now they determined what you're in
for.
Nonviolent and violent.
If you're a nonviolent defender,
you the world is yours.
The violent ones,
the ones that get lumped in with the
other ones.
So now the violent offenders,
uh,
depending on what you do as violent,
you go into one sector and that sector,
the longer you're in there in,
the more rewards you get.
So if you're in green,
you stay up till 10 and they got cable
TV.
If you are red,
you stay up till 11 and they ain't got
cable TV.
If you're purple,
you stepped on one.
One Am.
Oh my God.
Boulder County jail was tremendous.
So I figured I didn't drink milk.
Milk is big in jail because the
bodybuilders like milk.
It's like fucking drugs.
So I would trade you and you my milk for
your Koolaid.
Right?
So I was in there drinking fucking cool
shit because I fucking hate.
Boulder was a paradise compared to other
jails all listen to this thanksgiving
day when I was.
I locked up.
Thanks every day at the guard came in
and I'll never forget his name was ron
and he opened up the cell door and there
was a phone that was anybody who needs
to use the phone,
use the phone.
I figured out,
you know those days you had to press
mind that sideline.
I pressed eight to see if I get long
distance.
Not that press seven,
six,
five for a fucking long business.
I got the call my peoples in Jersey for
20 minutes a piece,
you know,
you just figure out different things.
Then they send you to a place where
somebody Lucia and stripped down and you
got to go take a shower.
Then you come out and they put a finger
up your ass to see if that's contraband.
They give you a tidy whities and orange,
like a rubber glove on and then loop
their finger up.
It doesn't matter at that point.
I didn't give a fuck.
You putting the finger up my ass.
It breaks you down with a man as much as
anything in the world.
That's the first break.
Now.
Wow.
The turn you around to let you go.
They you,
they going to stick it up your ass.
Then you go to Esl and those guys there
and are very nice.
They weren't like the Boulder County
jail guys.
Those guys would shake your bed and make
you get up,
turn your light on in the middle of the
night and say,
get out of bed.
We're going to do a search at two in the
morning.
Those people are not nice at all.
Then I got transferred to Summit County
jail,
which was a fucking paradise.
Paradise.
Paralyze handball all day outside TV
till two in the morning using your cell
black and white tvs and yourself.
Basic cable.
You could be up all night if you wanted
to go to breakfast,
you ate breakfast,
not you could sleep through breakfast
and we'd eat your breakfast for you.
And then from there they shipped me off
to the Department of corrections.
That's where it's the nitty gritty.
You think black people talking to a
movie theater at night.
Don't go there.
Don't go that black people talk all
night.
It's six or seven floors and I was in
there in August with the full humidity
canyon city,
Colorado.
Wow.
Alright.
Well a little window,
you know,
and I was like on the third floor I
couldn't read.
And in those days they let.
Yeah,
you can push hours a week and one hour a
day.
You went outside after that you were
just in a cell by yourself at night or
froze in the daytime.
It was like fucking been sweating in a
fucking 10,
10,
10 cans and the data that way finished
name Charles Shit has nothing to showers
and then the three meals and then that
and then the first week is good because
you actually get out of your salad,
go test.
They tested everything.
Your math,
your English,
they park and put a bunch of pictures in
front of you and they put you to
psychiatry.
They take your blood out,
they do everything and then they assess
you and then they have.
I took care of all of the dots.
Okay.
There's a bunch of dots.
You have to.
You have to dot your i's like if you
have a high school diploma,
you get a point.
If you were working at the time of
arrest,
you get a point if you up to paying
rent,
so I got a bunch of points for that.
It's so funny out to to talk about
something very interesting.
It's very interesting where this Harvey
Weinstein case is going to go.
It's very interesting where it's going
to go right now.
He has Benjamin Braf is an attorney and
if you see what happened,
Benjamin Bratt push for dismissal and he
didn't get it.
Lawyer
said the judge set a trial date,
date,
Harvey Weinstein's going to go through
them more money to pay off time
obviously to go for time.
That is going to fire Benjamin,
Braf and show up with two women,
primarily one black and one Asian or one
white and one Asian and this is when
this trouser,
and again,
very interesting.
Harvey's also in the higher millions of
dollars and prosecutor and a private
investigator's interview boyfriends.
They're going to interview this case.
It would be very interesting on like the
cosby case which caused me.
They've been really,
fuck.
How do you know he's going to do all
this stuff because I know this is what I
would do.
I know if you come to me and you go,
I'm getting busted for this.
What do I do?
Because of how I grew up around those
people.
This is what you do.
Benjamin Bratt cannot ask a woman the
same question.
A woman could ask a woman,
hm,
so I'm going to go in there with either
a black woman,
Asian woman,
or a white woman.
My first two choices,
or a black and an Asian woman.
You want to get the diversity angle to
get the diversity angle and I want to
get that.
You can't.
You're saying that because you're a
black woman.
Chinese woman.
What?
I'm trying to stare at me.
Did you ever really watched the people
versus Oj Simpson?
No,
I didn't.
Very interesting.
And it's time that you sat.
Now the holidays,
the effects version.
I watched one episode and seemed very
good.
Very interesting.
How he pulled a dream team together.
How it's going to cost you 10 mil.
Listen to me.
Gee,
you got two options.
You go in there like cars being paid two
mil and make believe you're blind or we
put together a fuck it.
Then you see him.
He wasn't there with that Milky Shit
over his eyes.
Like the guy from confo.
Let me.
When we were kids,
foods father followed was like APP blind
and shit.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Build the Magnesia design shit.
That's how be willing to playing like
I'm sick.
Routine.
He's got cataracts.
Who cosby?
Yeah,
but he didn't have cataracts when he was
like that.
When he put the pill in the water,
he didn't know.
He knows what.
He knows what the fucking.
So three steps.
Read your fucking,
you know?
Yeah,
he knows,
but harvey has to play this hand.
This is what America is about to watch.
They're going to watch something fucking
crazy.
He probably knows.
He can't go in there.
And Benjamin Bratt.
Benjamin Bratt.
Fag gravano.
Look at the list of Benjamin Bratt.
Says Benjamin Braf can attack a woman
show.
You look at law legal cases like
supports on paper.
Listen to John Jones versus Gustafson.
I went to New York last week
and I went to the Metropolitan Museum of
art with my daughter.
She loves art and while I was sitting
there I was added saying,
go on your own.
Because my daughter didn't want me
taking pictures in front of the statutes
anyway.
She's like,
Daddy,
get out of the pictures of the stash,
so I'm like,
what the fuck am I hanging out with you
for?
She was in the Chinese bringing.
I wanted to see the Armenian way,
but it was funny.
I was thinking about when I was 21 and
22 Joe Rogan,
I would get stoned to the gills and go
to the Museum of Natural History of the
museum or my hobbies back then since I
was such a loan and then people looking
for me,
I was always a criminal.
I would go over the bridge to either go
to one of those museums.
While I would sit in the courtroom,
I would go to a place that had a fucking
Italian sandwich and I get a bag of wise
potato chips in the 16 ounce coke and
you go to any court room.
Court starts at seven at the
metropolitan downtown.
I take the a train and I'd walk.
I forget now what you know.
This is 1983 81.
I was a kid and I would sit none
observed night.
I learned how to.
Plus I grew up in that.
You were what you would sit and watch
night court,
like you'd watch a basketball game,
like a pickup game with a sandwich and a
soda and potato chips.
I think a lot of people don't realize
you could just go to court and I would
want to do that.
12 people I would learn how to set back.
Can you do that anytime you walk and you
just get in there and watch and then in
the eighties?
Yes.
Now this bomb detectors,
you have that the reason why you're
there.
Do you have to like if you're interested
in the case?
Yeah,
he'd go down there and just watch it.
If you,
for whatever reason,
there's a speeding thing.
Like someone lost her license and they
got arrested driving and trying to get
away from cops or you can go watch that
and go get them support and Joe,
I'd like to go and see.
I would like to see what the fuck was
going on when those guys are trying to
get away from the cops,
helicopters chasing them with the
spotlights and they just keep going.
Like what the fuck were you thinking?
Like what?
I would like to get to that courtroom
hearing.
I want to see that guy.
I'm going to look at that guy that was
running from the cops.
Fucking spotlight from the helicopter on
me knew he wasn't going to get away and
he's cutting people off and driving the
fucking side of the.
Nobody ever gets away.
Has anybody ever gotten away recently?
Something that parking garage.
I couldn't find them in a parking
garage.
They get away with the percentages.
What?
The percentages are very fucking low.
It's tough to get away,
bro.
They got you.
Once those helicopter spot you running
through neighborhoods,
you've got to make sure you're going
into a mall.
They have cameras.
They can rewind the cameras and watch
you go.
If you're running into the mall and you
know there he is a spot on the card.
What happened here?
You want to know what happens here?
What happens to.
All right?
First of all,
usually spikes.
Skyline is following you,
so yeah,
they got to put you on the floor,
kick your legs,
do everything by procedure on camera,
and they pick you up the handcuffs here
and they put you in the side of the car.
The guide tells you this whole white
version of what happened.
The pursuit started on.
The vive wanted subject was moving and a
high rate of speed.
Fucking,
you know,
if I just had to chase you for 20 miles,
I pitched them my you.
It puts you in the fucking trunk.
They put you in the back seat in front
of her.
The cameras take pictures and they put a
cot next to you on the drive there.
You got a couple back,
hands to your face.
You know what I'm saying?
That you hit the steering wheel or
something a couple times.
Then you go in there and you sit in a
holding tank and then you fucking.
If you're with one another person use
you just shut your fucking mouth.
You want to call your lawyer?
I call them lead.
They want to call your lawyer because
you want one of the other guys to get a
lawyer.
So then like that you have to get a pub.
It's conflict of interest.
So me,
you and Jamie got arrested right now I'm
going to shut my mouth and tell you I'm
gonna.
Call my attorney later because I know
for a fact Jamie's going to get a public
defender.
So now I can't get a public defender
because that's conflict of interest.
So the state has to pay for a different
attorney for me.
Well a lot of people don't know that.
So you got arrested with two or three
people.
You keep your mouth shut.
Yeah.
Call my attorney later.
You have an attorney?
Yeah.
I forget his name.
Jamie cap.
But public defender now to public
defenders can represent.
You got a better chance of getting a
better attorney and the state pays for
it.
So next time you pay for your mortgage
to go.
God Damn it.
This state,
Texas.
That is because the jerk off like me
went.
We fucking johnny run battlebots and
fucking he wants $800 an hour.
Even though the state will give him a
$400 an hour,
it's like wholesale,
you know what I'm saying?
But I at least I got a better type of
attorney.
You game the system,
you game the system.
It really is fucking crazy how I love
figuring this shit out.
You will do your writing things down
like you wouldn't even think.
And you just automatically started
writing down numbers and percentages.
Shit.
Oh yeah.
I know this shit.
I grew up in this shit.
It is like a sport.
So that's what he'll do hot.
And by the time we bring on a rape case,
you got to go up there and we lived the
story and tell the dates and there was a
rape kit.
It's a very fucking tough.
There's going to be very interesting
pro.
What's going to happen.
The only thing is anything he cops to
come,
they gonna come back and I'm like oh Jay
and try this.
Uhm,
so just live in Florida.
Make them fucking super eight films down
there in Miramar,
Florida.
Wherever the fuck he got it.
It's crazy when you see somebody get
sued because they work the system.
I'm not saying nothing bad yet.
That's what your advisors and your
people around you Italia.
He uses hot water for the rest of his
life because even if he gets that down
to like an assault charge and he has to
serve eight months,
12 months,
which is really eight.
Once he gets out,
all the civil suits are going to come at
him.
Okay.
And then he has to pull an old jim moved
to Florida where they can't touch you
punch or some bullshit money at
something like that.
Wow.
It's really crazy.
This is not unrelated to what we're
talking about right now.
So this has happened I think since we've
been live.
I'm Kevin Spacey uploaded this video on
his youtube channel where he's in
character as Frank Underwood and since
this has come out today,
he's now been indicted on rape charges
and Matt Massachusetts,
I believe.
Whoa.
Felony rape charge.
So it's his plea to get his job back.
This might have come out without him
knowing that was gonna happen.
I don't know.
I was just.
See if you wanted to watch it and see
what he's doing.
Should we watch it?
If it watching,
we're going to kickstart tube.
It's fair use.
Ish.
I mean it should be definitely fair use.
We can always watch it minute or
something like that in a second seven.
See what he's doing.
He's washing his hands.
I know what you want.
Oh sure.
They may have tried to separate us,
but what we have is too strong.
It's too powerful.
Mean.
After all we shared everything.
You and I,
I told you my deepest darkest secrets.
I showed you exactly what people are
capable of.
I shocked you with my honesty,
but mostly I challenged you and made you
think and you trusted me even though you
knew you shouldn't,
so we're not done.
No matter what anyone says and besides,
I know what you want.
You want me back?
Of course she believed everything and
I've just been waiting with bated breath
to him.
He confess at all.
They're just dying to have me declare
that everything said is true and that I
got what I deserved.
Wouldn't that be easy if it was all so
simple?
Only you and I both know it's never that
simple.
Not In politics and not in the live,
but you wouldn't believe the worst with
it.
We'll see Karen characters 100 percent
supposed to be dead in the show.
Correct?
Weird.
Is that strange to watch?
It seems a little off his game,
right?
I mean it metal.
Nothing.
When I was playing Frank Underwood,
he seems a little off like.
Okay,
we're a little tense on that one.
Let's see.
Let's get into this.
You're Frank Underwood.
Come on,
man.
Kevin,
you frank it.
I'm Frank Underwood and then boom.
Hit it a second time.
It's the second take.
Felt smoother.
Second take.
You know,
it seemed like acting.
It's weird.
It's not like it's a great character and
that character is fucking great
character.
I mean the Frank Underwood characters,
like one of the all time TV characters,
but that's just weird.
He just brought them into real life.
What happened on the way for Statutory
Fox News according to Fox News,
but this is where everywhere else too.
He shared this video as he's announced
that he's facing felony sexual assault
charges for a salting,
a teenage son of a former news anchor
and nantucket bar in 2016.
He was going off on that powder,
who God knows the power they give you
what you buy in.
So just to make that tape just shows you
how fucking creepy.
Good.
I really think to be that good at
acting,
you gotta be out of your fucking mind.
Kevin Spacey's bad mother Fucker when it
comes to acting,
all the horrible things he's done aside.
There's a,
there's a quality about someone that,
that good,
you know,
they're just got to like a certain
amount of insanity to be apologizing for
his actions.
Everything he did is horrendous,
but it means to be surprised that you're
seeing him seem crazy there.
No,
that's not surprising.
He's too.
He's too good to not be crazy.
Like I would assume that they're all
one.
They're not crazy.
I'm shocked.
You know,
when someone is,
uh,
you know,
seems to like Daniel Day Lewis doesn't
seem to be crazy,
right?
It just seems to be obsessed.
It seems to be obsessed with work.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I think all of those brilliant
motherfuckers are out of their mind.
Just his out of his mind as Germany.
Horrible.
I did when I was a kid.
My grandparents did.
Shepherds are very smart,
intelligent dogs,
but they all have a cork know I record,
you know,
my mom wouldn't Luda hers.
She had a female bleed once a month,
which made him even fucking crazier.
So when I was a kid,
my mom had one that you can go to next
to a purse,
but buddy stink.
He had one of my buddies thinking he had
a German shepherd that was pure,
authentic.
You could walk in the house.
I have a great time.
I date and make a move for the door.
So he built all our friends in the ass.
He didn't like when people laugh,
every one of them.
So every one of us,
because of the extreme of what we do,
including yourself,
has to have some,
you know,
something you will on the phone last
week speaking about Bill Burke,
he wanted the helicopter.
He plays the drums.
He's a comedian.
He's a dad,
he doesn't let a minute series,
you know,
so hey,
you on a helicopter with bill birth wine
around the city,
but two nights earlier,
he,
you laughing,
laugh at him onstage while he made fun
of some fucking what I saw him last,
he was hysterical,
making fun of the Obama tour,
you know,
so you're following me.
Those extremities is what makes you good
at your main thing.
You know,
the fact that,
that fucking all those different things,
the fact that cowboy cerrone fights at
the high level of competition,
but then two weeks later he's high
diving off a cliff or motorcycle racing.
Not just that he does it while he's in
training,
while he's in training.
That's what makes people who the fuck
they are,
you know,
uh,
when it comes to drugs,
psychedelics or the hard shit,
you know,
you get these people that for years I
heard rumors about certain actors that
they show up on the set,
still coked up from the night before.
But give them three cups of coffee,
give him breakfast,
take a shower,
and then whoever they're supposed to be.
So for that last eight hours,
they kept it together for the other 20.
They were a fucking mess.
Look at guys like Nick Nolte.
Nick Nolte is one of the greats for
sure.
I mean unbelievable actor.
And he had some serious,
serious substance abuse issues.
And it's past Jan.
Michael vincent should have taken over
hollywood watch some mechanic.
You know,
we have.
Listen bro.
The Me too.
Movement was a great movement.
it made people,
you know,
whatever the words to let people know
what's going on.
But what happened to Marilyn Monroe,
she was the first meet to victim.
Marilyn monroe was,
if you look at it from an angle,
they passed around joe rogan,
between the president nick,
connie,
the fucking mobster in chicago.
And who else passed around?
She was married to mickey mantle.
She was married.
How many fucking times she was married
to the playwright,
tormented that pole girl.
Then they found her dead or whateVer.
No,
no,
no.
To me,
Marilyn Monroe,
Marilyn Monroe.
She's the first fucking original me to,
you know,
uh,
that,
that knocking down all of the gardener
and schrader on sunset boulevard.
But the last,
everything is closed,
then nerd melt is closed.
Everything is closed on that block.
You're hoping that's still open is that
flower shop.
They finally decided to close after a
thousand years,
but that was the flower shop where if
you wanted to take them and rod and
pressing,
you got to order flowers from that
flower shop.
That was what it was famous for.
That dimaggio sinatra,
everybody owned and flowers for Her,
for that shop.
If you knew her,
they'd say,
what are you?
What is she like loud flowers from that
place on sunset.
But she was the original.
Come on dog.
Think about how tragic her life was.
And she was beautiful.
She was young and I had them all.
But all of a sudden a slick young guy
comes along with his voice and his tight
shoes and he takes her away from me.
I'm a man that can not be familiar with
that dude tells waltz is nobody tells
robert duvall when he comes over and
thousands.
me once a natural in the movie and he
goes,
there's a piece ass.
And I've had them all and she was the
best piece app.
But just to show You,
it's not about dollars and cents.
I put singing lessons and dance lessons.
She was gotten to be a fucking star,
but all of a sudden you're a boy comes
along.
when is olive oil voice and his shiny
shoes.
And he makes sure he takes her away from
me.
I'm not a man to be humiliated.
You know what that felt like?
And he goes off on him.
He throws his fucking.
What's his name out the next morning he
wakes up in the dead horses.
That's right.
That's the speech he gives that sinatra
fucking took his girl.
That's right.
The horse in the bed scene was one
theme.
I was fucked up scenes ever in a movie.
Especially when you're 10 sell horses
head.
Oh they really?
Oh yeah.
They killed a fucking horse for that
scene.
A hundred percent.
That ain't a fucking rubber horse.
That's a real horse's head.
Do you ever watch it again?
No,
I don't think I'm mistaken.
I'm pretty sure I remember this.
I remember that it was.
I might have a magnet,
I think that they might fucking throw
you in jail today,
today.
Even then in the seventies,
you can get away with it way bert rose
made when he was throw the dog on the
plane and inspect the showed up and they
kept saying,
oh shit,
that's still moving leads to stump man
and jam.
MichaeL vincent comes to take his job.
There's an old Burt reynolds movie
hopper,
hopper.
That's a movie about burt reynolds being
the baddest man of all time,
but then jam.
Michael shows up and jam.
Mike was going to eat his lunch,
but then burt reynolds puts jam like in
this place and they make the jump in the
car together.
But the funny thing about that Movie is
that he has to jump out of a building
and the guy that played the inspector
was a wacky guy when he got here.
Jamie says,
snopes article.
It's true.
Divorce.
The studio had encouraged francis ford
coppola to use a fake horse head,
but he didn't.
He didn't like the
mockup.
His scouts founder horse ready for
slaughter at a dog food plant in New
Jersey.
The art director pick one that looked
like the horse in the film and said,
when that one is slaughtered,
send us the head.
He said one day a crate with dry eyes
came with a horse's head in it.
Fun.
Well,
sounds like they're going to kill the
horse anyway.
That's probably better than not using
it.
Right,
but people have attached.
We served horse rectum once on fear
factor and horse people got real mad.
They get very mad.
ThIs a scene.
Here we go.
You imagine being this poor fuck and
being entangled with the mom back then.
This is supposed to be filmed in what?
Like the fifties as well.
It was supposed to take place in the
fifties,
not showing it right.
Other people at home,
they can look okay.
It's a very famous.
What's really scary about this scene,
as they came into the house while you
were sleeping,
they wake you up and they put a horse's
head under your sheet message under the
sheets.
So lucky he realizes there's some blood.
Now he's looking around.
He's like,
what the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
How good is this actor?
Who's his doctor?
What's his name?
He's been in everything.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
He's looking at the blood.
It's all over his fucking sheets.
I mean,
it's fucking crate and that's real blood
too,
and there's a horse's head and he starts
screaming.
They chopped his fucking stuff and embed
with them.
That was like a prized stallion that he
had.
right.
He fucking took him that he assaulted.
He insulted.
He goes,
see you get on and I ain't no band
leader.
And he goes,
yeah,
I heard about that story because that
was the story michael tells to check
that that day.
How do you know sinatra?
She goes,
well,
my father's gun,
he's god godfather.
But he goes,
what does that mean?
And he goes,
he sang with the tommy dorsey band and
tommy said,
I'm not releasing them.
And they put a gun to his head.
Luca brasi pulled a gun.
He said,
you're either going to sign it or you,
your brain's going to be across it.
Which one?
That they paid a dollar for sinatra.
So that's why when this guy shows up and
he goes,
I ain't no fucking band leader.
And that was the last time he tells some
guy like robert duvall,
robert duvall says,
if you mind,
I have a plane,
are you driver said to get me to the
playing [inaudible] vito corleone,
he's a man of assisting bad news right
away and hearing bad news right away.
And he goes,
you go tell them.
And the next morning to fucking dead
horse,
jesus christ.
What a way to send somebody a message
though.
That was a good fucking movie.
All those movies were great.
I got the problem is that got italians
way to,
into being an italian.
They started over the crazy.
I will tell you this joe rogan and I
told you this a couple of weeks ago and
I know it's tough for you.
it's tough for me,
uh,
subtitles.
But this episode of narcos is really
been doing it all in subtitles.
No,
they got a lot of language but it's
tough for people to watch.
But like I told the guy who played pablo
was a bad.
Like I was saying the other day,
I was talking to somebody you don't want
man.
I grew up watching american movies and I
loved him,
but my undercurrent was watching spanish
television at night from the age of five
to eight and nine.
there was a couple novella is that I
really appreciate it and I kinda liked
the acting.
I was like,
these guys could fucking act,
but I forgot all about it.
And then I watched Man on fire and
managed fire.
Had some phenomenal spanish acting.
Plus they had the italian guy giancarlo
giannini.
How bad of a fucking.
How bad of a Motherfucking itali you
will get.
Name is gian carlo g and nini.
He's the one that was in a hannibal.
Hannibal stabs him and then fucking
closes his guts out in the fucking.
I don't know if you've ever watched
hannibal.
No one shows up and that's a wow.
He kills his stomach,
but he is the kopan man on fire.
The one who brings jesus to girl's ass.
Man on fire.
I had a lot of good like side actors,
but a lot of great spanish acme
services,
norcos and all to hold and all these
shows to come on back.
I'm watching these dudes and I'm like,
bro,
he's tied these guys from old soap
opera,
spanish soap operas,
which is tough.
If you ever did a soap opera,
it's a general hospital and let me tell
you something.
If I would have gotten off a plane and
on general hospital,
I would have gotten fired.
Thank god I was p at 12 and 13 years and
I knew my way around the set it and you
book or so bob,
nobody talks to you.
You know,
like you walk into abc over there and
got street,
you walk in,
they'll your id and they'd go,
go to room 27.
You go to your office,
you fucking your suits.
The lady coMes in and she goes,
how you doing?
My name is mildred.
Watch the tv and look for your numbers
to come up.
You sit down,
you're right.
Your numbers.
I'm in scene 27,
chapter eight and you sit there with
wardrobe on for
you.
I wouldn't go there at 8:00.
I'd be in my car and quarter at a tiMe.
Really?
How many soap operas?
General hospital.
Three episodes.
I find that three episodes in general
hospital was amazing.
I played a recovering fucking preacher
who had been in prison and I came out
and now I was a fucking marriage thing,
bro.
When they called me,
they called me.
They're like,
we're interested in you sending a real.
And I'm like,
wait,
whoa,
whoa.
So benjamin bratt.
Those good looking dudes.
They started on general hospital as you
want me.
Are you fucking crazy?
I sent them a real.
I swear to god,
man.
He just like,
they really want your real job.
What do you want me to do?
I go send it to him.
What do you want me to deliver?
Going to hire me,
bro.
They called right back.
Come on down for three days.
Wow.
You walk in there,
joe rogan.
You give them your id.
It's that fast.
You go to your room,
they'll say 28.
Prepare wardrobe.
You're 10 minutes away.
You put whatever wardrobe they give you
one.
They have cue cards for you.
Uh,
they have a year under a fucking another
cameras.
It's a three camera shoot.
You go out that says,
okay,
activism at 28,
come out.
You come out.
I ain't doing joe rogan.
Very nice to meet you.
Okay,
let's do this.
Action.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Let's say you fuck up your line.
They don't give a fuck.
Like if you start from all whole now
we'll start from that line.
Bop,
bop,
bop.
Cut.
Moving ahead.
While all of a sudden they switch you
out,
blah,
blah.
They put makeup on you and they're like,
you're not in the scene.
Just sit over here for five minutes,
bro.
Five minutes.
They come right back to you.
All right,
you're ready.
You're going to scene three and you're
like,
what the fuck happened?
Bop,
bop,
bop your wrap.
Thank you for coming down.
Nobody talks to you.
Nobody does nothing.
Huh?
So it's not a.
They're Just trying to get it out quick.
They don't hold youR hand.
It's eight to five.
Wow.
Being on a soap opera is probably the
easiest way.
Like if you landed on general hospital,
used to be in a general husband for 30
years,
that dude's been on there for 30 years,
you know,
you could be on there.
People been on it for a long time.
So it's eight to five hospitals that
luke and laura.
I was
Right.
Remember luke and laura know what
happened.
There was a thing that happened in soap
operas and it happened while I was a
kid.
Luke and laura transcended general
hospital and became a thing all
throughout the world.
There's people.
Well,
yeah,
these people didn't make sense because
the dude's hair was weird and strange
couple.
I did the scene with a dog.
They were weird.
Yeah,
I did the sCene with him.
She was a little too hot for him.
It didn't make a whole lot of sense,
but it worked for whatever reason,
it caught fire culturally and became a
big.
And I
think I was in high school at the time.
There were,
there were.
There was a 19,
83.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I was in high school while I was in
high school.
This was all going down and everybody
paid attention to luke and laura was
like the general hospital thing took
over the country.
It was like on the cover of people
magazine and shit.
It was everywhere.
It was this one weird relationship on a
soap opera for some reason.
Just became this gigantic phenomenon
that everybody was watching.
I mean,
I was watching it.
I was like,
I said,
30 million viewers.
Fucking crazy.
That is what was,
what was the show with the good luck of
sangha,
uh,
wishes.
She was jessie's girl.
Oh,
rick springfield,
general hospital.
St joe and I watched.
That wasn't even him.
See if him,
if he was with laura,
I watched.
He's a handsome son of a bitch that rick
springfield,
you know,
and he was a double threat.
He was on general hospital and he was a
bad ass singer.
That jessie's girl,
that song,
if you're at fuCking like wild wings and
jessie's girl comes onto you and excited
at the beginning of it that jesse's.
He's still out there hitting it.
Still touring,
touring.
I think he was at the canyon club and a
gora.
He's out there.
ThAt dude was when I was in high school,
that dude was on top of the food chain.
every girl had a poster hill on the
wall.
Lake town next month.
Good for him.
It's crazy that whatever soap opera was
on from 12 to one was a big time soap
opera and there was a bar in New York
and there was a bar in New Jersey and my
neighborhood,
if you walked in there from 12 to one
and you said a word,
somebody would tell you to shut the fuck
up and it was 98 percent men and they
would serve lunch and it was when I
would go to was the midtown lounge,
but there was another one.
So there was a lunchtime soap opera that
men left ed jobs for construction guys
and they would sit there and watch this
soap opera to tv's like it was a yankee
game.
What the fuck?
And then they will go back to work.
I have to get thiS train.
Is that.
How strange is that?
That was a thing.
It was a big thing at one point and I
still remember,
you know,
if you dated a girl and she stayed in on
wednesdays to watch dynasty bitch,
you stated on dynasty night if that
lookie cookie,
that makes sense for like today it's
translatable.
You know,
sunday night gaMe of thrones is on or
whenever night it's on.
It's like people do get together and
they watch it live as it goes on.
That makes sense.
What doesn't make sense is that the
market for those kind of soap operas
was.
It was appealing to men and high school
kids.
Like we're all watching it.
Who shot jr bro.
That's dallas.
But that's.
No,
no,
not now we're talking then.
yeah.
Not only were they sucking you in the
daytiMe in those days,
this was all the eighties were talking
about the eighties.
Okay.
What the fuck was going on at night?
Both.
You had dallas and you had,
what was the one on abc with alexis.
Can I ring the dynaSty and the guy that
was bad as a bad ass girl right now.
The checkup played the princess on that.
That was supposed to be alexis's
daughter and she was having an affair
with dexter dexter.
She's the one right now that's going
through that thing with a daughter in
the sex ring up in Connecticut.
There was like a sex ring novo or
whatever.
Like she's a princess life watches?
Yes.
She's the one that's going through all
that with the daughter.
I remember her being on dynasty as a hot
hot and she was alexis's daughter,
but dexter dexter was alexis's husband
and she had some.
Dexter dexter I'm going to rename is
tHat.
Look at that cast.
Joan collins.
She's still hot back then.
She's the original milf,
right?
Yeah,
for sure,
because she was super hot.
How old do you think she was back then?
50.
Yeah.
She was 51 and she was rushing that.
She was hot as fuck and look at ricardo
month and bomb.
How much he.
That dude got paid on that fucking
island.
How they.
How they haven't done a remake of
fantasy.
They did a comic book.
A couple comics went out there and did
it.
Yeah,
they had.
They had.
It was on tv for a little bit.
No,
they fuck wasn't the love boat was the
boat.
Am I confusing it mom before fucking.
No,
but I mean the new version of it was,
there was either a new version of the
love boat or new version of fantasy
island.
So one of the two.
Neither of them are showing up near
there.
One dynasty actually was,
but it was in the nineties.
It was,
um,
it was in the nineties because,
do you remember cherry red wilson?
the next show?
Jerry redd.
Wilson was supposed to be filming that.
What was it?
Which one was about the love boat?
Cherry red wilson was supposed to be
filming that show and he,
uh,
went to a doctor and turned down he had
meningitis and I guess apparently he
left the doctor's office because he was
waiting and he,
uh,
by the time he got there,
I guess flying when you have that really
bad,
by the time he got there,
he died.
Wait.
Died shortly after.
It's horrible.
Horrible to hear.
Who's a good guy?
Good guy.
Funny.
So you had a lot of fucking character.
I worked at that kid a lot in New York.
We did gigs together on the road
together a little bit too.
That was a good little click.
I remember bleeding in seattle.
He came up,
louis c k came up.
All those guys were all coming up
together at that time in New York,
so it was a good bunch of guys,
you know?
Yeah man,
they do remake a lot of fucking
television shows.
I mean it is fucking ridiculous thing.
They make so many shows.
It makes it like.
Is it that hard to come up with a new
line of thought?
like how many more va zombie shows
they're gonna have to have a new zombie
show.
right?
I think they're making world war z as a
team in China,
but there's a new,
a walking dead in China now.
I Think like,
okay,
that I think I know what's going to
happen.
Bad things,
you know,
like you have a.
When you were growing up.
I don't know where the fuck you grew up.
Let's just say boston for awhile.
That was one fucking sandwich shop and
he wanted to and guide because he made
you legit sandwich and all of a sudden
another guy opened up,
but that was cool,
but now subway came and now the safeway
started making sandwiches,
so now nobody's making money.
It's the same thing with movies and tv.
It's like there's so much content we
can't keep up with.
It caN't keep up.
You can't keep up with the amount of
content that's out there,
so when you try to remake a show,
I want it to be.
They really make a ton of shit,
but they forget the main element of
which is the heart aspect of it.
Let me tell you something you got to
say.
That's good.
That's out right now on amazon prime.
Marvelous.
Mrs maizel tremendous.
He watched it.
Yeah.
The two episodes.
Mountain.
Yeah.
She's.
She's a stand up comic and she's hanging
out with lenny bruce.
It's fucking amazing.
It's a good show.
It's a real good show.
This is the first show I've ever watched
on amazon prime.
It's very easy to do.
You just set it up through the apple tv
with log in,
baM fucking thing.
Fuck off.
It's like the thing about like things
like apple tv or netflix that are so
good is once you're logged in,
it's right there.
Right?
you go to it.
It's easy.
We're so lazy now that the extra step to
log in to another service,
whether it's whatever it is,
you know,
another thing on top of the getting onto
itunes.
So I got even one More thing.
Oh,
I gotta I gotta use my password.
They're like that little extra step.
Even just setting it up.
once you get it set up,
you could just go to it,
but before you do that,
that extra step bothers the shit out of
people for whatever reason.
Ease teas.
I go,
I just had My wife program for me.
Have to go to the plan.
I put it in airplane mode,
I hit the wifi thing and next thing you
know i'M watching fucking tv.
I get it.
I try to keep it like I'm wearing right
now.
I'm on the second time of watching
narcos in Mexico because I liked the
acting so much that the guy,
diego luna,
joe rogan ain't no joke.
That dude waS in dubai mba and it's such
a difference.
He's such a bad ass motherfucker.
I don't want to spoil it for you,
but fuck you if you haven't watched it
by an I.
You slipping and watched the first two
seasons.
Do you watch the pablo seasons?
Which were.
He was very good.
He was a very good act.
I enjoyed them.
Then the third season with the cali
cartel and that was,
okay,
this mexican woman just sit alone on
this.
We're fully based from when you watch
this shit explains a lot.
Why felipe?
Based away from the payers.
I tell you what,
if I could move to solo,
I would.
I belong down there.
it's just a city full of fucking fucking
crazy shit.
Just crazy.
And they figured out how to grow weed in
the desert and they were making
$30,000,000
a week,
a bunch of crazed fucking indians,
but we never found out how much.
What percentage of marijuana that we
used to have is you're right,
but it's also really hard to test back
then and they weren't testing back
testing and strongest weed.
I was smoking back then was chocolate
pie.
With that,
we've made me go fucking crazy.
Someone had explained to me the
difference between strains that were
raised in Afghanistan and strains that
came from other places.
Like right now,
dean or friends from the store.
He got a seat from afghany wheat from
the old days.
Shit.
So he denies that.
I guess the word they use is not the
word and he keeps trying to get that
seat,
but I still remember smoke.
Any weed you will go for,
you were going for a ride,
but you're.
Your tolerance is so high now and the
weed,
you're smoking his weapon grade.
I mean you're.
You are.
You are smoking some of the most insane
wheat.
I ended up.
Wait a vape pen the other day.
A simple little vape pen.
I took one hit.
I was a blitzer rated right now.
Damn strongly are now.
You've got to be really careful now.
I was cocky.
I was treating it like the old ones,
especially those disposable ones.
You can take three,
four heads before even feel it.
One hit of biliterate it,
but especially since I stopped with the
edibles.
That changed the game.
Yeah.
Double drop.
Changed the game of you are 100 percent
off the edibles.
Hundred percent.
I god,
our buddy george has thousand milligram,
had a booth and they gave me two bags.
I think like tonight.
Oh,
I'll take a bite out of the other book
because it's christmas,
but I had to cut it out because it was
just killing me.
It was,
was taken away from my other high.
I enjoyed taking it.
So over pipe in the morning gets me
going,
gets me listening to music.
I'm writing a little bit.
I'm loose.
I love being loose with title nine at
two isn't me.
I enjoy that shit.
I can't go on the road.
I don't bring pipe
so I got to bring the.
Sent me.
If I got to come down off the 11th floor
and walk two blocks,
I got to smoke the whole fuck of the
drawing,
so I got to go back to my room and pass
out.
Like that's how strong the witness I
could just kills me.
Especially now that I'm not eating them
anymore,
just kills me.
Mama finds me.
I go back to the room.
I watched three episodes or somebody I
think about this.
Scientists making wheat now.
I mean they've gotten.
They got real botanists involved.
There's money in it now.
Now that it's opening up in Canada,
it's going to be really weird because in
Canada they're making it legal,
right?
It's legal now,
so I'm.
I'm pretty sure rj reynolds is that who
it was.
It was just dumped a shit ton of money
and to some marijuana production in
Canada that's going to file suit in the
United States.
It's.
There's too much money involved in it
and it's going to be good for everybody.
It's going to Be good for capitalism.
It's going to be good for people getting
marijuana as long as regular people
could sell marijuana to let fucking rj
reynolds as long as they don't put some
restrictions like they were trying to
put.
Was it you?
Jamie told me about what they were
trying to do in Ohio where they were
trying to make it set up where you
could,
you could grow weed,
but only a couple companies could grow
it so that we would be legal,
but only a couple of companies would
monopolize.
And then everybody was like,
fuck this.
I ended up passing it.
I believe that's terrible.
It's sad that,
that mean that's such a corruption.
That's like saying,
okay,
you can have tomatoes,
but we're the only ones who grow these
tomatoes.
Like why?
It's a tomato.
That's a law against nature.
So you're saying that nature can't take
place.
I can't put a seed in the ground and
grow my own shit.
Get the fuck out of here.
Is it legal?
It's illegal.
Okay.
How's it different than corn?
How's it different than a fucking,
uh,
a pear tree?
It's not,
it's a legal life form.
It's a life form,
it's a plant.
You're allowed to grow it,
and if you say can't grow it,
you got a corrupt system.
You got some bullshit law that you
weaseled in because you greased up some
assholes and the other people don't have
as much money as you do.
It's the only reason why that ever
happens or people are so desperate to
get legal weed.
Did they let some dickhead dominate the
entire industry?
Some greedy.
Fuck,
no.
The deal is it's legal or it's not
legal.
Otherwise we're in some sort of a weird
dictatorship.
You know this is not.
You can't just dEcide it's legal,
but you're the only one who gets to make
money.
Fuck you.
It's a plant.
That's crazy.
Imagine if you owned all the pine trees
in the country.
Don't make my country my pine trees.
You want to buy pine?
You're buying it from me.
I find you with a fucking christmas
tree.
I'll take you out.
It's crazy though.
What happened last week?
I don't know.
New york who said he's wanting to
legalize weed.
Oh yeah.
He wants to make it recreationally.
Legal in New York.
Stupid to shoot down.
You should be making money off of it.
It exists.
No matter what you do.
If you're a capitalist,
if you're a person who believes in free
market,
you already have whiskey,
you already have pills.
People can get high.
They're not so just.
They're just not.
Stop with the child is arguments.
Give the fucking people freedom and make
money off it.
You dummies.
That's what everybody should be doing.
They should make it legal and profit off
of and they.
It shouldn't stop with that either.
She'd go to mushrooms,
should go to a lot of different things.
They should set up clinics,
set up places where people can go
through mushroom therapy.
People that have suffered there coming
back from the war.
Ptsd,
you know there's,
there's so many different bands for
depression.
People that are getting ready to,
to,
you know,
to pass away.
They have extreme anxiety.
A lot that is alleviated by mushrooms.
People that have gone through extensive
cancer treatment and realize their
terminal.
One of the best things for these people
as mushrooms that helps them ease their
pain and suffering and their last dying
days and it doesn't seem to have any
negative effects other than the
occasional person losing their fucking
marbles,
which is going to happen no matter what
you do.
It's something that should be studied
and it's something that should be free
and it could benefit people so it should
be fucking legal.
I think if everYbody modeled with
colorado's going peoples see it,
you know,
there's a lot of naysayers and just
business.
They don't understand that in Colorado
you get tax rebates.
Not only that,
colorado's real estate went through the
fucking roof.
You know,
this is,
this is something that I hope most
states go for.
I know that there's a backend angle to
it.
It's a gateway drug.
It's this,
it's that.
It depends what you do with it.
You know,
I'd only argument is traffic fatalities.
this the only argument and I we had a
lot of increase in traffic fatalities,
but what I've read is it depends on who
the problem is.
It's hard to find the study.
That's absolutely correct.
Some say there's been an increased,
some say the incurrence increase
corresponds to the population increase.
I've read that too.
I don't know if that's true,
but that kind of makes sense that if you
get more people in the city,
you're going to have more people
driving,
going to have more traffic accidents
periods.
So if the number just goes up,
but the population has increased by 14
percent or whatever it's done.
That would kind of make sense.
But also,
let's be honest,
some people don't drive very well when
they're high and if you're out there
driving high and space now and you're a
fucking idiot,
you might slam into a car that's
entirely possible too.
And to deny that that's possible.
Seem silly,
but I think that it's like everything
else,
there's people that are responsible
people and there's people that aren't
and there's people that are good drivers
and there's people that aren't his
people.
That drive is tracted as people that
don't pay attention to shit.
And then there's people that.
do you know,
whether they're high or sober.
I would rather have you driving a lot of
people driving sober.
I know you don't fuck with your phone
when you're driving.
I've seen you drive,
you drive,
you take it fucking seriously.
You look around you not.
You're not interested in getting any
stupid car accident because you weren't
paying attention.
I've seen you drive.
I'll fucking take you high any day of
the week.
Idiot was a cell phone addiction.
I drive very defensively.
I watch everything.
I watch everything coming from all
angles.
Especially.
You
have to double check everything when you
drive.
A dear friend when we lived,
when they leave me got hit by a car dog.
Yeah,
I heard three weeks ago crossing the
fucking street.
She broke both her legs.
Yeah.
I want people to understand that you
have to have your eyes open and I don't
take nothing for granted.
I don't care if that guy's stopping
there when I'm making that right.
I'm watching that motherfucker.
Plus I got to watch for pedestrians
because they will walk out.
Anyway.
Next thing that you drag them a guide
three fucking blocks.
So I did not know the window was hit by
a car.
Was in a car accident?
No,
she was,
there was no right away.
The whole thing.
I mean somebody was telling me the
story.
I mean it was just you have to pay
fucking attention.
So I drive.
There's only a little New York and my
drive is only a little New York and my
drive number two,
I drive away from people I to take the
two or three colleagues.
I never did that till about 10 years
ago.
Larry.
Or is it somebody you know,
you're,
you were driving in a place where you
have to assume unless you fucking
stupid.
That 30 percent of the people for the
last 10 years have been driving high.
Then you gotta add another 20 percent
for people that are texting and driving.
Then you gotta add another 10 percent of
people are just visiting it and looking
around going,
oh my god,
look how beautiful California is.
It's a fuck.
Every time you get in the car you have
to drive a certain way.
Was it how I thought 20 years ago?
No,
I want to get that.
Why do you think I'm against high speed?
Cause I want to do 90 joe,
I'm getting a porsche,
I'm doing nothing.
I ripped the ticket up.
You give me a ticket.
I'm ripping it.
I knew you were going to get one of
those cadillacs for awhile,
but you decided not to because I got.
I got a for you ever see my feet,
my foot just very large.
They're very large and once they rest on
you,
it's 90 on that gas pedal.
I made it to san diego and back.
Don't say anybody.
Don't.
Don't tell me.
I tell people the secret.
It's not illegal.
I'm sick and tired of people coming to
me going,
oh my god.
The drive to san diego was horrific.
What time did you go?
One of the afternoon.
Can I smack you down or should I smack
in the mouth later?
That's four hours.
That's three and a half.
But isn't that crazy that it takes that
long?
But if you get in your car at nine and
you do fucking 80 because all you need
to do is get out of la.
Once you pass the commerce casino,
it's a river dirty.
Nobody gives a frenchmans fuck.
You stay in that second to left lane and
you're just doing 75 baby.
It's an hour an hour.
40th five on the way back.
Made it from la jolla and our 30.
Whoa,
because I.
That's easy wrap.
Soon as you hit the five north,
you're banging out the hallway quick all
the way to camp pendleton,
navy.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't give a fuck.
You fucking serious on its nobody out
there.
It's a weird hair and I know too,
when you're coming back from san diego
says military zen,
you're hitting 80,
80,
80.
Then when the road starts to thin,
that means you're about to hit
immigration.
They're going to ask you if you got an
unregistered that never out there.
Those motherfuckers happened without
this nine slash 11.
Right?
You just,
once I hit that point,
I kicked it to 100 till I hit irvine.
Once I hit irvine spectrum,
I come down to about 80,
80,
and then I see la 19 miles back up to
100,
but then you're going to hit traffic.
Oh my goodness.
You're going to hit the 10 to five.
Everybody's it up.
You get on the one on one,
but then I get back on that one.
Thirty 4:34
and the five goes until 1:34
and next thing you know your own no
drama.
the night driving from san diego.
It was the way to do it.
Yeah,
definitely want to drive home after the
kid.
You don't want to wait for the morning.
Fuck.
sometimes you're so tired.
You're scared.
No,
no.
That morning,
that morning and two hours.
No,
you stopped yourself a nice coffee and
you fucking zang it all the way back to
loss.
No,
you're righT.
That's what you definitely should do.
But man,
you know the the key for folks who you
worry about falling asleep in your car
while you're driving,
get a rag or a tee shirt and get some
ice.
It's the best wet rag with ice in it is
the best.
Just rub it on your face real quick and
you wakes you right the fuck up and it
lasts for a few minutes and just do it
again a few minutes later and you'll be
fine the whole way home if you can keep
ice and uh,
uh,
like a wash cloth or something like that
with ice in it and it gets wet.
JusT keep rubbing your face.
It's better than anything.
I useD to smack myself in the face when
I was getting up early in the morning to
do newspapers.
I was delivering newspapers.
Then I would do gigs at night.
I was fucking tired,
man.
And I'd be coming back,
you know,
at midnight from thiS gig and I knew I
had to get up at 5:00
AM to deliver newspapers depending upon
the day.
And I would just smack myself in the
face because I was falling asleep at the
wheel.
I would just feel my eyes getting heavy
and I'm opening them up and I couldn't
keep it.
I just fucking whack whack yourself in
the face.
It lasts for like a couple of minutes.
Like you're like,
gee,
I would just,
my whole face would be stinging,
you know,
it's like seriously slap myself really
hard in the face.
I will never fucking coffee guy.
Like as a kid I mangled and cuban coffee
straight away from it.
So when I first started triple runs,
I wouldn't have my kid at two in the
afternoon on sunday and I would get off
stage and boise,
Idaho at 1130 on
my car would be filled with gas and I
get it.
I didn't have four or five bills,
no dogs.
And I would go to a gas station and get
the biggest mountain.
Do they ever had an airline?
And that would go for six hours.
I would eat no doz,
but one of the worst experiences I ever
had was I was falling asleep like I was
done and it was fucking 10 below zero,
you know?
And I pulled over on the side of the
road.
I turned my lights on,
I put the brake lights on,
I kicked the seat back and laid down
with the heat blasting and the car was
on.
And at one point sharon and I opened up
my eyes and I thought I had lost control
of the call.
In your mind,
you feel like if I lose.
And I remember holding onto the steering
wheel,
he has my heart almost stopped and
going,
thank god and get fucking hit here.
well that was a no dose.
This is way before red bull,
red bull,
whatever that shit is.
But I still remember doing coke all
night and shooting a short film fox.
And I'll never forget the fucking.
They gave me two red bulls.
I drank two of them and I still fell
asleep and I.
This is that.
I go red bull.
The fuck is a red bull.
I'm going to fucking red bull onto dick.
What do you think it is,
John Jones?
Shit that's going on.
Do you know what's happened?
The ufc is moving from vegas.
So this last night when I got home from
the comedy store,
break it down for me.
Jeff novitsky.
Come on and break it down scientifically
on thursday.
A lot of people are calling bullshit,
including daniel.
I talked to call me on the phone.
He was like,
he tested positive again,
can you believe this shit?
And they get a little fight.
I found out about it from cormay me.
He told them they're going to move the
flight to la.
I go,
no.
He goes,
yes,
joe,
that move With the fight down.
I'm like,
no,
this can't be real.
it didn't seem real like I don't believe
this.
I looked at his core age,
twitter and I said he tested positive
again and then I looked at when,
what this is like first thing in the
morning and he's like,
keep ti again again,
but from what I understand from reading,
ariel helwani is a transcript of his
interview with andy foster and hearing
what jeff novitsky has had to say about
it.
What it is is the numb the.
The amount of it is so infinite decimal
and it's the exact same metabolite that
he had been screened for that he tested
positive for a year ago and that this
shit could stay in a system in those
kind of sizes of the molecule.
It's like some $500,
million of a grain of sand or something
like that.
Google what the actual number of the cow
small molecule is,
so andy foster has said again this
transcription of this interview that he
did with ariel helwani that it's the
same metabolite for the same substance
they tested positive for that is as the
same instance that the,
the number of it and it indicates that
this is something he's already been
punished for.
The same exact.
He's already gone through his steps and
this is just an infant testimony,
small metaBolite.
That's what I'm hearing.
So I would love to hear someone who
doesn't think that that's the case,
that thinks there might be some way to
game the system and the big thought that
people always bring up when it comes to
this stuff as micro dosing.
Someone micro dosing like you're the one
who told me about that first.
You were telling me about a somebody
Alex Rodriguez who is taking a gummy
bear testosterone and he was so he would
be up for the seventh,
eighth and ninth inning,
but by the time the 10th and then came,
if they tested him,
it would be out of the system.
So I would imagine the testing is better
now and this is one of the things is
that novitsky wants to get into that.
The testing is far superior now,
so you're able to piCk up these
metabolites in much,
much smaller quantities.
So this is.
So this test is from december nine.
Yeah.
I want to see what his tech here it is
leading up to that apparently was
cleaned before that said we were
notified early this month.
Have an issue he has had over his most
recent tests were very small amount.
I'll,
I'll pack describe how small it is.
A of a longterm,
a tablet substance called d h empty,
known as oral terryn Nepal trendable,
which is the reason for his most recent
suspension a year and a half ago.
A very,
very small amounT.
But there was a number that.
Where does it say the number?
There was an ak rife or.
Yeah,
something like how much smaller.
It isn't a grain of rice is it?
Can't find it.
I'm just trying to find it.
Um,
yeah.
Look,
I get how everybody would be fuck and
pissed.
I get how everybody would think that
he's a cheater.
He's cheating again.
I get the you would think that,
but I don't know if that's true and if
it's not true,
it would be ashamed to accuse him of it.
If it is the same stuff that was in his
system that was ruled to be from a
tainted supplement.
Here it is.
A pickle is 1000000000000th of a gram.
Novitsky said if you put one grain of
salt on the table and split it up into
$50 million pieces,
a pickle.
Graham is one of those pieces of that
gram of salt,
which is insane.
so that grain of salt,
it's a $50,
million times larger or smaller than
that.
It's crAzy.
So it's very,
very,
very small.
So if this is true and they believe it's
true,
and the guy who runs California state
athletic commission,
andy foster,
I have a great,
great deal.
Tremendous amount of respect for that
guy.
Very proactive with weight cutting,
very proactive with weight classes,
very proactive with a lot of the rules.
He's really good.
If he believes that this is
scientifically been proven to be from
the same exact thing that he already
been punished for,
I agree with them.
I just that that guy knows what the fuck
he's talking about and he's legit.
So as novitsky.
So are these people that are all saying
that it's legit.
Here's the question though,
have other people been still punished
for the exact same crime?
Have other people tested positive?
Again for the exact same thing?
This I do not know and I don't know if
people are looking into that.
If there is any preferential treatment,
that would be where the argument would
be.
Preferential treatment is fucking
tainted.
Supplements are legItimate problem.
I mean novitsky showed us hundreds and
hundreds of supplements you could buy at
any store that has,
you know,
vitamins and muscle builders and all
those kinds of things that test positive
for steroids.
There's a shit ton of them out there,
man.
You can get a lot of stuff in these
systems.
But then there's also people that are
taking steroids.
So how do you know who the only way to
find out who's,
who is,
don't take shit,
don't take anything unless it's third
party tests that don't take anything
controversial,
don't take anything squirrely.
And sometimes people do and it's fucked
up that you know,
they,
mayBe they lack a supplement,
maybe they've had good results with it
and then they get one bad batch.
That's possible too.
I just wanted to know that this was from
December 9th.
I want to know what the levels of that
drug they found where before the summer
night it takes a long time ago.
Well I understand so,
but every time your urine,
the level should get lower,
lower,
lower.
I think what they're saying is this is
the lowest detectable number.
So there's no lower than they should
have found this before.
Maybe not higher.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Depending on the city is numbers.
The way it's been explained to me,
and again,
I'm not a fucking scientist,
but the way it's been explained to me
this number is so small that it could
conceivably be tested in one test and
not tested another test.
And then also as the testing procedures
get more and more thorough,
they get better at it.
They're detecting things they couldn't
detect.
maybe even just a year ago I gets
continued.
The the technology is continuing to grow
and they're getting much better at
understanding how to use it and how to.
How to advance it.
so it's not as simple as you test
positive a year ago,
you test negative today like they.
They might have better methods of
detection today than they had a year
ago.
You've got arrested today.
Joel judge is going to say,
joe rogan,
I'm released on bail,
but the da wants you to take a urine
test.
Samples come back dirty.
The first year was free.
They know who joe is going to go
in there and you're thc levels are going
to be off the chain.
This is going to be off the chain.
This is going to be up to chain.
When they come back,
they're going to coin and they don't
know joe rogan.
This is what it was.
Now this is this.
The next time we test you behind in 26
percent because we know you're using.
This is in 1997.
The lady told me,
I'll know if you use that and I stayed
through the program and I went down,
down,
and then I joined the voluntary group
and my buddy sent me an eighth of weed
and I remember smoking a joint and going
back and the guys like dog.
Did you smoke a joint before you came in
for the test?
It was like levels.
ThIs is I'm telling you about this.
This is
funny joke and whatever,
but I want to see the test before the
ninth and I want to see the test.
The most recent test,
those levels had to go down.
I do.
I understand what you're saying to us
necessarily.
Correct.
Unless he did the steroid during non
competition season,
which they're allowed to do whatever the
fuck.
No,
they're not.
That's not true.
They never know what they know.
They can never take steroids.
There's a banned list of things they can
never ever have in their system.
They say if you're up fighting,
they'll still test.
You.
Say if you don't have a camp,
you're not in camp,
you don't have a bout lined up.
They still still tested joey diaz.
How are you?
Come on in the bathroom.
We're going to get some get some fluids
from you now I don't know if they using
just urine or if urine and blood.
I'm not sure what the protocol,
but I do know that it's very thorough
and they're catching people for things
that they would have never caught them
for in the past,
and this is one of the things about this
test.
It could possibly be as it's been
explained to me that this,
this number is so fucking small that
they might not even been able to detect
it a year ago at this number,
this insanely small number.
There's new levels of detection now.
Whereas he would be completely negative
x amount of time in the past.
Now they can test it and they could find
that insanely 50 million of a grain of
salt size particle.
It's.
It's so fucking small that they weren't
able to catch something like that x
amount of time in the past,
whether it's a year ago or two years,
but now they can and then the future
it's going to be even better.
They're going to keep getting better at
this stuff as they advanced the
technology.
That's,
as it's been explained to me,
what you're seeing heRe,
what you're seeing here is not evidence
of new drug use.
It's evidence that the testing is far
better and that he has the exact same
metabolite anD he definitely did have it
in the system because they're finding it
a year later in these te,
te,
te tiny amount.
His body hasn't completely gotten rid of
it yet.
Still in there.
The question is how long has that stuff
stays in your system?
They've said through normal detection,
I believe google this,
make sure this is correct,
but through normal,
what's not?
I mean from whatever the time they.
They wrote this stuff out.
I believe they were saying it can be
detected up to 18 months,
but again,
as this technology gets better and they
can detect smaller and smaller
particles,
it's potentially possible that that
might extend.
So you might not just be 18 months,
it might be 19 or 20 or who knows how
long it takes for your body to get rid
of that shit.
The other guys like columbia and
gustafson and guys,
you know,
they look at this is where there's
smoke,
there's fire.
Yes.
You know,
and they have a point to.
They have a point though,
so I'm not mad at them for that.
I'm a big fan of the show of John Jones.
Personally.
I am too.
For what he does.
I love him to death and I saw him at the
albuquerque game show.
We lacked.
I don't think,
I don't know what to think anymore.
You know,
I don't know what to think.
This one really,
you know,
and I feel bad at you and I both know
this is the card of the year.
It's a phenoMenal cause.
The card when peOple fly in and then
make plans around that and they do a
bunch of stuff around it.
I feel bad for those people.
I know what this is like for them.
They just lost this saturday night
activity.
Well in vegas it takes a big hit too
because this was going to be taking
place in vegas.
All those people are going to be in
town.
It's gonna be a tremendous amount of
money for the casinos and you know,
I'm sure it was a lot of money for them.
There is a big thing to have there and a
bigger arena,
so they're moving it to the forum which
is a smaller place.
The foreman,
inglewood is,
I don't know how much smaller it is,
the tb mobile arena,
but he said he was a.
Dana was saying he could make about
$6,000,000
on the gate at and t mobile arena and
he's going to be lucky to make a million
in the forum.
That makes sense.
It's just,
it's different prices to in vegas and
also the fact that it's such short
timing.
I don't know what they do with the
original tickets.
I don't know how it works.
This is what happened.
The very first ufc I ever did,
the very first ufc ever work was in
dothan,
Alabama,
ufc 12,
but was supposed to be in New York
state.
They cAncelled It in New York state that
would let them do it.
And they,
they,
they switched the whole thing overnight
down to dothan,
Alabama wouldn't take one of them
helicopter plane
and flying a fucking dope.
And it was weird.
It was weird back then,
man.
But that's,
uh,
that's the only time I've ever heard of
something changing this close to.
That was one day.
This is one week.
I've never heard of an event changing
like this before.
Not that I can remember.
I don't know what the fuck is happening.
I really don't.
But they seem very confident that you're
not dealing with someone who's taking a
drug.
Again,
you're dealing with the very same drug
that he took x amount of months ago.
Still in a system the drug has already
been punished for.
I understand that people get mad,
but um,
you,
you don't want to accuse someone of
something that they're not really guilty
of.
He's definitely guilty of taking it the
first time.
People are accusing them of being stupid
and taking it again.
I don't think that's true.
I don't know for a fact,
but what I'm reading from actual experts
leads me to believe that they're making
sense,
but I would have to,
I'd have to talk to someone who
disagrees,
who knows more about it than me to
really form an opinion.
So my opinion is like,
wow,
if I had to Bet,
I would say he probably didn't do
anything,
but I would like to talk to someone
who's like a real fucking expert who
could break down exactly what the
process is,
who can tell you if it is even possible
that this could be from another
ingestion somewhere along.
The sad,
sad thing about this whole situation is
what they really,
really from the bottom was a great card.
Oh,
it's a great car.
Even when bj penn is on the car that
nobody even talks about it.
You mentioned bj penn.
Well,
you know,
bj's tough fights.
I was looking for carlos and michael,
uh,
you know,
Amanda Nunez and cyborg.
I haven't slept for a week trying to put
the car down.
The figure that fly that jon jones
gusteson just to look at it.
Let's pretend it's still in vegas.
You know,
you've got a guy who's been active,
a guy who's been fighting,
a guy who's angry guy who felt he beat
John Jones the first time against a
very,
very talented,
dangerous arrested.
John jones is their ring dust.
You know,
their ring rust.
I'm sorry,
what the fuck am I talking about?
You're the look at the man.
The cris cyborg has been bitch slapped
and motherfuckers since day one.
Amanda nunez is something that you
taught me about that's not around
anymore.
And that's being slick.
Amanda nunez is very slick.
She's taken out some tough opponents.
You know,
she hits very hard,
very long arms.
Really watch over us in carlos kind with
Michael Chase.
This is a great fucking fight right
here.
You know,
America does.
Alexander vulcan fuckIng tremendous
fight to Chad mendez.
Amazing in his comeback fight when you
grow up with.
Scroll back up to the cris cyborg.
I read chris corie.
Anderson's a leather is real heartbreak
and his wife,
seven months pregnant now.
They got to get away.
You know,
this has to be.
It's a disaster,
but this honestly guys was one of those
cards that I look at and go,
okay,
what are the main two fights?
I know favorite paper.
You got to go outside.
Borgen jon jones.
But guess what?
People you've never seen a buggy with a
part time job,
so somebody has got to lose one of these
fights.
Keeps growing.
If you don't mind seeing thing about
chris cyborg is she's not just good.
She's good.
And ball and gannon on Megan Anderson.
Andrea alaska's fighting on this card.
She's australian.
You got to say meagan,
meagan,
whatever dog.
I'm no fucking english major.
And you got bj penn,
ryan fucking hall.
I think that's the first fight of the
first fight of the crazy.
Yeah.
I saw a picture on instagram the other
day.
She looks phenomenal.
She looks fucking phenomenal brown,
so it's a shame that this had to be
done.
I'm sorry,
I'm,
I'm happy that the fight are taking
place.
I'm just happy that they're taking place
or that everybody gets to life disrupted
and the families have to go from vegas
to la to see the fight.
I'm sorry about all the hotel bullshit
that they have to deal with,
but uh,
I'm very happy that the fight is still
taking place.
I would love it if uber ran the fucking
special for people just to flat.
Yeah.
Just run a flat for fucking people out
of vegas.
300.
Never gonna happen,
but you never know.
You never know.
People need fucking action.
Come on,
let's go step up.
Bitch.
Make a flat rate for three fucking
people fucking forum and $300 back.
People would do it.
What's driving in uber?
Some guy farting in the car all the way
from vegas to la.
Why would you do that when you take a
flight?
Because the flight is going to be.
It's not that expensive.
Uber's is on a day's notice.
Is it?
How much the southwest cost?
It's 2:55.
Here's $300.
300 teachers in a car with a guy
fighting for three hours for three.
300 divided by three.
I save 200 something joe.
Right.
you have to look at them from their
perspective.
You know,
they've already fucking taken away and
they lose a day of work.
This is a lot.
Well also they can't gamble like a lot
of people love the combination of
gambling and going to go into the show.
a lot of people stuck.
A lot of people.
Gonna fuck it.
I'll just take my money from the ticket.
Yup.
And stay and gamble next day or whatever
because what's it going to cost me to
uber,
to la?
Get out party who?
You're going to come to a lady just
getting the car if you're trying to tell
me.
No,
you Want to go to a party?
Who?
My uh,
uh,
what's his name?
John jones might be having a party call
was kind of doing my babbling an after
party.
Uriah hall.
I think you're right.
I was on this card to his.
He wasn't in the new year.
Uriah hall's on this card,
I think.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Bj penn.
Oh wow.
Okay.
We didn't see it.
Look at this part.
You got to know who's having Brian Kelly
as fighting curtis mill under that is a
fucking sleeper fight right there.
Yeah.
No,
he's a fucking beast.
Curtis.
Mel under that guy is.
He's got serious potential.
He's got like superstar future superstar
potential and he's very good.
That's a good fight.
I liked that a lot.
In curtis mill under
is the one he fought.
Tiago alvarez and stopped them.
Right.
Click on that.
Make sure that's correct.
Does it show his record?
Show his record.
How good is there a website now?
It's pretty good.
Yeah,
that's it.
Tiago alvarez.
he beat thiago.
Alves.
YeAh.
And then he beat max griffin.
He's a beast man.
He's a very good,
real,
a real massive future potential.
And by her design it knocks people dead.
He hits hard.
That's a sleeper fight.
That's a fight that no one's talking
about.
Very,
very good fight.
It's going to be a great card,
man.
I'm happy to cards happening.
I hope everybody gets compensated.
I'm sorry that the ufc loses money.
I'm sorry that everybody gets dragged
through.
I don't understand why they couldn't
just figure out this in Nevada.
It's like I guess they're on vacation or
some shit.
That's so crazy.
Like figuring out how everybody.
Let's make a phone call like it.
Isn't there one person who could like
some person should say.
Okay.
Is it to the best of your knowledge?
Absolutely.
From the original task.
Yes sir.
By all the science,
we're going to submit the science and
we'll show you the science.
We dIdn't tell you the number.
Okay.
Let them fight.
If you have let him fight California,
let him fucking fight in Nevada.
Stupid.
How fucking stupid.
It's just stupid that in this case it's
this case.
It's approximate their own vacation.
Well,
that's a with emergency meeting.
Let's save vegas.
The tourism board of vegas must be
steaming.
hey,
ask this.
Ask this,
google this.
Find out who's disputing.
If anybody dispute if anybody makes any
sense.
if there's a scientist or something like
that who says that it could be
microdosing or that it did.
What the California state athletic
commissions understanding of it is not
correct.
Let's find out if there's anYbody that
has written anything about that.
I'm upset.
I just wanted this fight to take place
without any bullshit behind it.
I just want it to be a great fight.
It's a.
It's an amazing matchup.
I think gustafson especially against
glover,
to share has never looked better.
He's.
He's long as john.
He's got crazy footwork.
He's the first guy to ever take jon
down.
It was a fucking tough fight regardless
of whether or not john prepared much for
it.
I don't think he did prepare as good as
you could have a gustafson's better,
I think than he was when that fight took
place.
I really do think he's better.
It's a fucking phenomenal.
it's an amazing fight and john's going
to be so motivated to try to get
stripped away.
He gets tripped.
All the different things that he's
fucked up to have a chance of
redemption.
It's going to be so motivated,
but you also have to consider the
incredible amount of pressure.
He's going to be under two.
Historically though,
he's a guy who shines under pressure,
I mean stop shogun and it's first title
fight when he was,
what was he?
Twenty two or something like thAt.
He's a monster.
John's always been good at fighting top
level competition.
good at handling the stress,
but this is you.
It's a different kind of stress.
This is.
I fucked up stress.
It's not.
This is a big fight.
Plus I fucked up and everybody knows I
fucked up and this is not even the
current fuck up.
It's reminding him over the past fuck up
and then there's the other stuff,
the car accident and all the other crazy
shit.
All of it's bad,
but He has an opportunity at redemption.
It's just when you know how much is on
the line because he's undefeated,
right?
Except for matt hamill fight,
which we know he was destroying hamill
and he was disqualified.
Wasn't a real loss like somebody beat
him.
He's beaten everybody that's
unprecedented outside of khabib number.
go ahead off.
Nobody beats everybody.
John's beaten everybody.
So there's going to be a certain amount
of people that are looking forWard for
him to fail and he feels that too.
So a lot going on,
man.
It's a lot going on in this fight.
And gustafson is fucking good.
You received a combination.
He knocked out clover to cheryl with.
Ooh,
that's like some video game shit man.
It was like he was in mortal kombat was
tremendous.
His footwork,
everything.
I was really.
I got to work saturday night.
I'm work.
I'm alex.
Not all weekend.
Oh,
you really forgot.
I thought it was just last week.
Um,
so I thought it was this last weekend.
So I called the store.
I called in and then I go,
fuck no,
I'm not missing that.
I called back and canceled and then like
wednesday I go,
what the fuck am I thinking?
So I ended up back at the store saturday
night.
I squeezed onto brian show.
I got to see tiffany haddish.
I hadn't seen her since she busted out,
became a star.
It was great just to see her and
bullshit with her.
And then last night I went down and
there was two shows and it was,
I'm leaving.
They're like,
hey,
you want to open up for chappelle?
I go,
chappelle,
when he knows he's doing the show on the
belly room,
there was a fucking line around the
corner on the sunday that I pulled that
out.
I was like,
this is crazy.
This is so fucking insane.
That took two weeks off from getting
onstage.
I have To la jolla.
I did two nights and law and that was
tremendous to joe.
Rogan is amazing.
You don't owe is the room you go into
when you want to put.
You want to thread that out again?
They take the ride with you.
That's one of the few rooms.
This takes the right way.
You do two shows a night down there.
That place is amazing.
It's like a comedy store south.
Yeah.
Really?
It's a little bit more loose.
Even though it's friday to saturday.
We'll let you try some new shit.
Fun people down there,
man.
very fun.
That's a nice area.
Like diego has a lot of the same
qualitieS that la has,
but it's more like a little bit more.
The rest of the country
is beautiful.
Even went to rada jujitsu.
I train when they that the place is
right next to the fucking calm.
they store.
Really?
Yeah.
I just looked it up.
Called guy was 11 either.
La jolla is.
That's where you moved to when you got a
lot of gators.
That's a lot down there.
He lives on that corner.
Natto island does donald rumsfeld.
I don'T know who lives out of rescues,
but it is just gorgeous.
You can see at night there's no lights
on the streets.
There's nothing.
They ain't carriage that listening.
Nine Thirty.
Go to bed,
go to bed,
go to bed now.
Right?
We don't want you all to mingle.
Go fucking down the side.
Whatever.
The street.
Scotty short lived down there.
He showed up.
He showed up on saturday.
be a hug.
It was great to see him.
He has a little dog with him.
He had the little dog because I do a
joke,
but I had to get his dick suck with a
dog,
so he goes to the inspire dog and go,
no,
I didn't see the dog.
He came down to see lou still playing
the piano.
I mean the comedy store down there did
not lose anything except mitzi shore.
Plus It's got more shit on the walls
that you look at.
It really makes you think there's
pictures of green rooms and jim carrey
and Paul Rodriguez and dice clay and
louis and this time,
but they didn't even know that we're
going to be stars.
We'd done down there.
Can we tell a lot of shows?
It shows.
When did we first started working
together?
Down there?
I think the first time.
Yeah.
I was like the late 90.
The first time I went down there,
went down there with a girl.
Who was it?
I don't remember what her name was.
It was a very uncomfortable weekend
because she was clean.
All you have to stay in the condo with
her.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's crazy.
Already.
Dirty girl and being forced to stay in a
condo with a guy that you don't even
know.
She stayed in the headline of room.
I stayed in the feature room at that
time still.
It's weird.
Then I went down there.
She wouldn't book me down there.
Once you started booking me,
she booked me lot.
Mitzi?
Yeah,
and I remember going down there one time
and I went down there with martinez and
her husband and we weren't there and an
hour and Maryland martina's husband
comes out with a fucking rat.
Well,
with a rat trap trap that he said he
weren't here motherfucking because the
rumor was there were rats down there.
Be careful.
Oh.
so he went down and set traps up within
our unit.
Bob.
Oh my god.
The fucking thing had to be nine inches
long.
The tail.
And I'll never forget going on the
balcony and then hearing them in the
weeds.
I packed up my little sleep apnea
machine and I fucking drove back home.
I fucking hate rats.
I fucking hatE it.
Well,
the store has so many rats that back
area.
Oh my god.
They're fucking popping out every
time you sit in the back there.
There's a little,
uh,
for folks that are listening to this,
there's a little back bar area.
We're only comics in.
Their friends can go behind the back
bars,
a smoking area,
and that smoking area has these railroad
ties and these railroad ties.
These rats will run in and out of these
ties and over the top all the time.
All the time.
If I'm back there for more than 15
minutes,
I'm seeing a rat and if you go near the
hedges by the dumpster,
that's where they really are.
Where we're.
The back area is not that big.
It's the hills.
The hills are filled with rats.
The hollywood hills are filled with rats
and occasionally we have cats that hang
around the parking lot of the comedy
store,
like local feral cats,
but they don't get the rats because the
rats go in the fucking.
The vines,
thOse vines that covered the side of the
comedy store ramp,
the ramp that leads up to the
[inaudible] hotel.
Those vines are all rats.
That's a rat village.
It's crazy how much sound they make when
you're parking the car.
You hear them scurrying.
There's probably hundreds of rats there.
Dude.
I parked my car but I'd dump site closed
the windows.
Oh,
because I know I don't want to jump into
a car with a fucking listen to me.
I just leave fucking.
I leave a aspen.
I owe like $80,000.
I got eight people looking for me to cop
some looking for me.
I go from aspen to boulder.
I needed a job so I take a job making
joe,
I'm not kidding you.
One 60 a week,
60 hours as a fucking shag,
which I'm the guy that takes a car from
you in the body shop when you pull up,
takes it and I wash it and then they
struck the body work and then after
they'd done the bodywork,
I'm the guy that washes and it'd be do
that for three or four months.
Then they turn you into a detail and I
passed the test and every game of detail
and $160 a week.
It was fucking garbage.
I was starving,
starving,
but I was good and I became a detail.
The detail room was commissioned and you
made 100 to a buck 50 a day and you
know,
I was enjoying it,
but the guy I had as a boss was.
His name is derrick Jordan.
He was just a day though.
He was one of those guys that was one of
us,
but when they get a manager's job,
one that I'm back there washing the
fucking car and I see a dead rat.
I picked the fucking rat up and he had
his jacket hanging by the door.
I put the dead rat in his pocket of his
jacket.
Know though I go home,
I get stolen.
I don't know that the next morning he
comes in row and it's fucked up.
Like he hit like a pole.
He went in his pocket to get a cigarette
and he pulled the fucking ride out and
he fucking just went crazy.
They're like a ball and running.
I know who did this.
I'm going to get to the bottom of this.
And he kept blaming some other guy.
My boss's.
Fuck man.
That's one of the worst relationships
ever,
but boston employee,
one of the worst relationships some guy
gets to tell you what to do.
He's the fucking.
He's the head guy at the office.
You gotta listen to this.
Fuck head is one of the worst positions
to be in working for a guy who's a dick
and that power that someone would have,
you know,
if you were,
you moved on up,
became the office manager.
He can control people's future control
where they get a raise,
how much time they get off.
You can make the decisions whether or
not you allow them to do certain things.
Fucking bullshit.
Come on,
be clean.
But what was the first guy you looked at
and said,
you don't want.
If I ever see outside of the ama,
fuck you up.
I never said that,
but uh,
guys in construction,
they would get real dickie.
I did one time,
there was a guy when I was a teenager
that was talking to a bunch of shit.
He would hit me with a hammer.
Yeah,
there was a [inaudible] he got.
He got aggressive with me and it,
it wasn't in a way where,
um,
I deserved it.
He was just bullying me and I was like
16,
17,
but I had already had a fuck load of
fights by then,
like,
you know,
talk about no fights.
I was like,
did I,
oh,
kick you in your fucking head.
Like you talk a bunch of crazy shit to
me like this.
Like he was talking to me in a,
not just a way,
like a boss employee.
He was talking to me in a way where I
was going to have to quit,
but I never,
never,
never said I was gonna do anything to
him.
I didn't threaten him and say,
I'll see you after this and I'll fuck
you up.
I said,
don't talk to me like that because I
could fuck you up.
That's basically what I said.
But that's the thing about construction
is like,
there was a lot of like man demand type
conflict.
Like it wasn't unheard of to hear about
street fights between guys who are
working together.
They got pissed and pushed each other
and punch each other in the fucking
snow.
You know,
dudes carrying roofing tiles.
One guy knocks another guy over or
something.
They start fighting.
That shit happened all the time.
There's a lot of the people that were
doing labor too.
We're like real dirt bags.
Like there was this one guy that I did
labor with.
I worked with my friend leroy rodriguez
and his buddy.
They have some business partner.
They would take apart old houses and
redo them.
And leroy was one of the black belts at
the taekwondo institute.
He was a bad motherfucker and uh,
leroy got me this gig and uh,
I've worked with these guys labor and in
one of the guys we work with lived in
this fucked up,
abandoned building and what not
abandoned but stripped out building.
I mean,
there was parts of the building when
there's no floor was all fucked up.
Half the
walls were missing.
They were redoing the whole building and
taking things out and fixing things.
This guy lived there and he had a
mountain dew jug filled with malt liquor
and he would drink it warm all day and
he had the shakes.
Everything he did to do have the shakes.
He was just drunk all day on a crazy job
site where like,
you know,
there's no floors sometimes everything's
all fucked up.
You have to balance when you're going
from one room to the other because
they're tearing down parts of the wall
and this guy somehow or another fucking
slid on through drinking the entire
time.
And I remember thinking like,
these are people that have made
questionable decisions.
It makes you want to go back to college,
makes you want to get a degree when
you're around.
A lot of these guys like laborers and
stuff like,
you know,
some of them are just like me.
They're just young guys who need a gig
and they need money and some of them are
dudes have been doing it their whole
life and they're 50 and they're drunk
and terrible by yourself.
If I want to do this,
I definitely knew I didn't want to do
it.
That will be a carpenter is a different
gig,
you know,
like a real good carpenter that's a
skilled craftsman and an artist,
you know,
you're putting together things that's
different,
but the labor gig was not like you
didn't really have to know anything.
You just had to be big enough to listen
to them,
you know,
picking up to like pick things up.
Can you go get that?
GO get me that bag of cement.
Go dee dee.
All right,
you guys are going to take nails out of
these boards now.
And iT was like that kind of shit.
You just hung out with the weirdest
people meant
the worst guy.
I remember joe rogan.
I was cleaned from coke.
I was clean about 90 days.
I was really trying to turn my life
around and I answered an ad
construction,
a carpenter's helper,
and he hired me.
I went the first day you had to work for
free.
For free.
Yeah.
So I said,
okay.
I agreed to it.
I made our first date worked for free.
I cut this stuff and you've got to go
get lunch and the whole thing.
Yeah,
okay.
I did it.
I passed and then the guy would say,
okay,
meet me at a diner at eight and when I
go get paid,
he'd say,
what's those hours?
And I go,
you told me to meet you at eight.
He goes on no job or windshield time.
So let's say that job,
we didn't get to the job by 10.
That's when you start getting paid.
That's when I started getting paid and I
was,
you know,
I was at,
I was really trying.
I lived with a friend that wanted to
give them rent money.
I was trying to put away some money.
I forget what he paid me.
He didn't pay.
He made me pay for my own lunch.
Then one day he said,
uh,
where's your white belt,
your work belt?
Like I don't have one.
He goes,
okay,
I'll pay you have to pay me for the
materials.
Plus 30 percent,
30 percent.
YeAh.
You're a fucking scumbag just to have
like a claw up fucking hammer and a
something else.
I forget what it was to work for him to,
to have your own and stuff like that.
Yeah,
there was always a thing,
um,
whether it's union or non union,
you know,
there was a lot of.
The work that I did when I was a kid was
non union and a lot of the people didn't
want a union.
They felt like the union guys,
they had it easier,
but it was,
it was too expensive and people didn't
want to know,
use certain people.
So it's,
it was like a real debate.
Like whaT's better is for every amount
of union people,
you have to have a certain amount nine
union because that works to balance it
out.
Right.
So everybody makes money,
but it seems like in some things like
auto workers,
they don't fuck around.
Right?
Like everybody has to be under
construction is different breaks,
glory time lists.
If a job opens up,
how do we get it?
You gotta go on the list.
Rogan has little minority than diaz.
He started nine months before diaz.
He gets the job.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not about knowing all that shit
with that.
Dude.
I'll never forget that news and what he
did,
the scumbag he was to me,
but um,
fridays he would make me feel bad like
he goes,
so how many hours did you work?
And I'd go 38 a,
no,
I'm paying you for 30.
And he bullied me,
this guy,
but every friday go this friday I'm
going away.
I'm going here to fuck my wife and the
ass.
And he was always an asshole.
And Then all of a sudden I got my
concern,
my check.
I got this checkout was waiting for and
one saturday I'm sitting down,
I'm like,
I'm sick of this motherfucker.
I'm going to rob his house.
and I jumped the fence and I kicked the
back door.
And he was the guy that bought hot shit
on the side.
He stolen the guy was just a bus sack
that shit.
And he must have had,
I don't know how many fucking bottles
and cases of dom perignon.
so I fucking ran up to the corner,
call my buddy,
go meet me at this address.
And I took every bottle of dom perignon
and he had,
I sold them at liquor stores.
I took his checkbook.
I mean I buried this fucking guy.
Just how bad he treated me with such a
fucking scumbag.
Never bought lunch.
He was always making credit.
You know?
He's always making little fucking
remarks.
Well,
that's what we were talking about
earlier.
What happens when a guy gets into power?
That's a piece of shit.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
I remember I had this tee shirt for a
long time.
I useD to work and smile every time jay
has some shit like that.
Fuck him.
That's half what this harvey weinstein
thing is about,
right?
It's about the boss.
Yeah,
that's what it's about.
It's about the boss abusing his power to
boss fucking the girls so they can get
the job.
And that's the offer which has probably
been going on forever.
Like I said,
especially here.
Listen,
they destroyed Marilyn Monroe and that's
the ones we know of now.
Millions,
millions of women that have come out of
here.
I been put through a fucking process.
It was always what?
How these guys got power.
I mean,
if you look at a guy like harvey,
how else is he going to get laid?
Let's be hoNest.
I mean,
is he going to get laid because he's a
good looking guy or is he going to get
laid because he's ruthless and very
successful?
It would have to be ruthless and very
successful.
I want to know like of some slept with
him and did a lot.
Well,
I don't know,
that didn't win,
but I mean there's a lot that did the
story is that there was a lot that that
did it.
I mean,
he,
he couldn't have made these offers.
All these women that said,
no,
I'm not.
Have some of them say yes,
it doesn't make It any less horrible for
the women who said no and were hounded
by them and whatever went down and he
ruined some careers and.
But some of them had to say yes.
It's just some would make that deal with
the devil.
That happens with a lot of different
things.
People make that deal,
they make that deal.
It's worth it.
You know?
I mean,
I joked around about it and my act about
harvey weinstein,
but that's,
that's what a lot of guys would do.
A lot of guys a bang,
some check If that's all it took and you
can get ahead.
You know,
you don't have to marry,
you just have to fuck her.
How many guys would do that?
A lot of guys would do that with girls
do that too.
Some of them,
yeah.
Most would not want that to be stuck in
front of their face.
Most would rather make their way through
the most.
The vast majority would rather get by on
their merits,
but there's always for throughout time
there's been people that fuck the way to
the top.
That's not a myth.
That's not like angels.
It's not like pick season would else.
People have done it.
People have done everything that you can
imagine.
People have married people for money.
People have killed people for their
insurance premiums or their insurance
policies rather.
That's.
That happens when people die.
They checked the spouse to see if the
spouse had a fucking insurance polIcy.
If they find that they recently put out
a big fat insurance policy,
then they go sideways and go,
oh teacher,
and she just vanished in the woods.
Huh?
That's weird.
mike.
mike,
have a seat.
We're going to talk.
What happened again?
Mike,
let's just take me through the top.
Tell me what happened.
You can just go hiking in Colorado with
one.
That was another one was another one
that just happened in Colorado with the
phone.
Ended up in Idaho.
Miles away.
They saw her leave the supermarket with
the child.
He supposedly picked her up.
I want to know how he got the phone up
there.
Every car's gps now.
Yeah.
Car.
Unless it's an old truck or you know
there's.
There's cars that they have the don't
have gps.
This cars.
You can get them stripped.
They don't have shit in them,
but I get a really cheap car.
truck.
Pickup truck.
No radio.
That's the.
That's the one that baffles me.
How to fucking get the Idaho.
How about the fucking guy killed his
whole family.
How about that guy got kIlled.
His wife killed his kids.
You hear about that guy?
Fuck jesus christ,
and he looked so normally you see a
picture of him and as mr came,
yeah,
to
mrs heyman,
but you look at him,
the picture him with his family.
You go,
that guy looks so fucking far more
capable of killing his own kid.
How is he capable of killing his wife?
there's certain people out there that
just fucking broken.
They're broken and you and if you're a
woman,
you have to think about that.
That's the difference between women and
men.
That's the bIggest difference.
The biggest difference is women have to
constantly be in fear of a violent man.
Whereas men rarely are in fear of a
violent woman.
It doesn't mean it doesn't happen.
It happened to my friend phil hartman,
his wife shot him while he was asleep.
That did happen,
but the vast majority,
if you're looking at the numbers of
people that are afraid of the opposite
sex,
it's women that are afraid of men.
It's a different environment.
It's a different.
It's a different dynamic.
It's not like anything that we could
ever really,
truly appreciate it.
If you know how to handle yourself in
that case that happened in Colorado
where he killed,
Is there any past the best of violence?
I don't think so.
We just snapped one day,
bro.
It doesn't make any sense that this guy
here.
Like I said,
the only thing that flows you off is her
car folded.
I know.
Which meant he had to take her right
there,
drive to Idaho,
which has to be 11 to 12 hours and drive
back 770 miles away and drive back
without nobody noticing.
It's totally possible gas station
attendants recognizing a truck with a
child in the back.
You know they have to do a search of
every gas station camera to see if he
pulled up and they didn't find him.
I didn't.
I don't think they've even gone that
deep so far,
but they got to figure out our cell
phone ended up fucking mailbox.
I just don't understand where people get
the fucking.
It is so tough.
The ice.
Somebody.
Now you're going to get away with it.
Between cell phones,
drones,
cam pictures.
Think about you.
Think about it.
How they find that?
Everything.
It's way more difficult,
that's for sure.
But a rural area,
rural areas,
you can still get away with the law.
No,
no,
no.
Look at that chick that was jogging from
the university of whatever.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
They buy the whole Iowa,
Iowa,
and they caught her with a something a
quarter with a drunk.
I don't know exactly the number.
It's very tough to.
I gotta pee so bad.
Well then go ahead.
Do your thing,
brother.
I'm going to have pets.
Talk to jamie and I'll come back.
I'm not done yet,
but hurry up and shit like that.
It's thE holiday season.
You're sitting around right now thinking
you see what's going on with joe rogan
as what happens when you turn 50
motherfuckers,
so prepare you to drink your water.
You try to be healthy,
but you got to pee all fucking day.
This is what I live with every fucking
night I go to bed.
I'm nice and sleepy and at one point I
got to fucking.
You got up and pee and you got to and it
comes out nice and slow to really
torture you to really make you think
about that ham and cheese sandwich and
the fucking refrigerator so you stay up
and eat that fucking thing.
That god.
It's merry christmas time.
This is the best fucking time because
listen,
I ain't doin dicto thursday.
You understand me?
How about you jamie?
Nothin nothin.
I ain't doin dictal thursday tonight.
I'm going to gracious with my wife and
kid.
We're gonna.
Sing mingled jingle bells and all that
shit.
All the kids get together.
I'll probably be home by nine tomorrow
and doing deck.
And how do an open mic at the gym
tomorrow for jujitsu,
I might have to go down at 12 just to
get some exercise so you can use an
excuse to eat.
I'm thinking about dropping into their
store on christmas night.
It might be boring,
but it might be an adventure.
Then wednesday I got dick for thursday,
friday,
saturday.
I'm up there and parks.
Not at a level he lives.
That'll be fun listening.
It's the weekend before new years.
Will the folks on this show,
people are going to be waiting for new
orleans because that's what people do.
They go,
you know what,
I'm just gonna wait for new year's eve
and jump up and down.
I fuckin hate new years eve.
You understand me?
I've always said since I was 18,
eight new year's eve,
you asked me,
why do you ain't pocket new year's?
Eve does weird things happened when I
was 18 or 17.
I saw an rx seven had a fucking tree on
new year's eve.
When the car got split in half and they
had the kid was dead.
The girl got taken out By the jaws that
then the following year I went to a
party and I saw my buddy danny be bite
off roger here and we had to drive me to
the fucking hospital with a piece of air
in the fucking baggy with ice cubes,
so that's why you never saw me drink on
new year's eve any other time.
It even through you at 364 days a year
for me to snort coke and he pills and
drink.
when it came to new year's eve and
minding my fucking business,
why?
Because it's just a creeping.
In fact,
I'm excited that joe rogan's not doing
new year's this year.
I saw that.
Is that what happened?
The guy fell asleep.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Walked away.
I heard probably because he was asleep.
I thought it was in a dream.
It didn't stiffen up.
That was in another country,
right?
Like olivia,
dude,
I paid more than I've ever played in my
life right now actually.
That got my blood done recently.
Got everything checked up.
Everything's groovy,
but I was dehydrated so I've been making
a point to drink more water.
What if I keep myself d hide,
but that doesn't make any sense.
Could I drink during the show?
But I want if I do that subconsciously
to limit my needing to pee during three
hour conversations.
No,
I don't think so either.
I drink water all fucking day.
Every time I won't go to the dentist.
A doctor for a physical.
He always says,
drink more.
You die.
well,
he used to always just drink more water.
It doesn't hurt.
And you know what?
I,
I sleep with water next to me,
which is big d,
get up and have a sip of water.
I'll get up pee,
drink a fucking gown,
the water because of the sleep apnea
machines to put a fluid in the.
Well,
I just bring a bottle of water with me
next door,
right to the bedroom at night.
And it's really important if you read
it,
there's a reason.
There's a reason why,
you know,
because when you're over 50 you pee
more,
but there's a rate.
you have to look it up when you're by
yourself next time in the hotel room,
there's a reason why you should sleep.
Diet hydrated when you're over 50 big
reason why.
Well,
whenever I can,
whenever I gO to yoga class,
I always feel like,
uh,
I have to make a conscious effort to
take that fluid back in because you
sweat so much.
One of those hot yoga classes,
like if you don't make a real like
conscious drink,
if you're thirsty,
you got to make kind of a conscious
effort to get those fluids back in your
body.
And you probably should take some
electrolytes to some sort of
electrolytes up.
I just blast the fucking banana,
man.
That's good too.
I blast to bananas.
You stay full for an hour to two after
you eat.
I drink water and I also drink a
fucking,
uh,
the after workout drink.
Sometimes bananas are good right before
you work.
No pump,
no calories,
no sugar,
no gatorade,
no fucking monster energy drink.
I don't touch none of that shit.
I hate all that shit.
You all that's just going to kill
fucking people 20 years from now.
Monster energy and all those energy
drinks and shit like that.
They don't kill people on.
My favorite thing is just coffee before
any kind of workout.
Just coffee.
Do you know that before I go to the
store?
You know,
before I go to the store,
I'd drink a four express shots.
I usually drink one of these,
either shameless plug,
caveman nitros,
even my wife ago.
How big is that thing?
And I put that cancer sugar in there and
I fucking get sugar free.
Sugar saccharin again,
that fucking call.
And I don't know,
music is sugar.
It's just me and four cups of express
over.
Do you know what's going through my
mind?
If I have the ball,
sometimes I take a toke off the pipe
just to cook the espresso upper level
and I pop a nicotine gum.
Oh my god.
You.
I'm juiced up by the time I get to the
comedy store because that's when I put
myself through the nicotine.
Nicotine guM is supposed to be legit.
Like from what I understand,
nicotine itself is a really good
nootropic.
They've,
they've analyzed the cognitive benefits
of nicotine on its own,
but it's addictive.
So it's,
it's nicotine gum is very healthy for
you,
but if there was a way it giVes you a
juice,
right?
If there was a way to blast nicotine,
like maybe chew it like a tobacco,
like a clean tobacco.
Just to give you a little push off the
cliff.
Yeah,
I think it's not bad for you.
I remember one,
one of the things that it really shocked
me,
the cops were looking for me,
so I jumped on a bus in san francisco in
1985 and I didn't even know the buses
going was going to a place called reno.
I had never heard of the marina and when
those days you could smoke on a bus and
met a kids from whatever Egypt and he
smoked with me.
At that time I was never touched tobacco
product,
never even consider it.
I thought I'm cuban.
Cigars were the worst thing in the world
for you.
And I remember we smoked a joint with
hash.
We end tobacco in it.
We Thought,
huh?
What year was this?
Nineteen 85.
We smoked a joint on a bus.
I don't.
My lungs were going to fucking cave and
when the tobacco and the hash east,
because the problem with ashes,
no matter what you smoke hash,
it doubles in your lungs.
What do you mean it?
The smoke doubles in your lungs.
How's it do that?
I do.
I look like johnny fucking scientists.
Next time we'll have these smart guys
comes on this show as well.
I usually smoke hash.
I take a pen.
You know those pens that people put
jewelry on fire,
put it under glass and put it under a
glass and you smoke it clean because the
way that we.
That straight the ash and there was
something else with double up in your
fucking lungs.
That's why you call so hard.
I remember when it expands,
expands,
expands.
I remember when I was a super square,
I never did any drugs,
never smoked pot,
never did anything and I went to a,
an a,
an agent's room.
I think we're in montreal.
It was me and my manager and this agent
who was a friend of ours and he had a
piece of hash that he lit on like a
thumbtack under glass.
He blows and it blows on it and he puts
the lid on it.
I'm watching him and then he smokes the
hash out of it and I was like,
I can't believe I'm seeing this guy do
drugs.
Like this is like a scene in hollywood.
He's out here.
He's doing drugs.
He's smoking drugs like says hash.
You know what I thought of hash that
fucking movie midnight express.
That's what I thought.
Oh my god,
you gotta go to jail for life.
You're going to jerk off on the glass
like you're gonna have to fight someone
and kill them.
Midnight express is about smoking hash
from Turkey.
That's in my mind.
Hash was a serious fucking drug like
this guy was doing heroin like you're
doing hash.
You might as well be doing heroin.
I was like,
I can't believe she's doing this in
front of me.
Smoking hash and front,
the people with a glass scares the fuck
out.
It's a for someone who doesn't do
anything like that's a big hit.
The hit of a joint.
He took a hit of a joint and go,
okay,
god likes to smoke pot.
I've seen that before.
You light a piece of hash and put it on
a thumb tack and put it under that glass
and get there and suck it out of the
glass.
You creaTe a drug addict,
your speech sniffing and exhaust fume
the fuck are you doing man?
If you know anything about me,
you know I've seen some people do some
drugs shit.
When I was in New York and when I got up
early and there's a movie called sugar
hill.
You don't want sugar hill.
Sugar hill.
I remember the sugarhill gang related.
Sugar hill is a movie that is possibly
wesley snipes.
Best movie.
That was when they were the drug
dealers.
Drug dealers can.
the alexander opens up the movie.
Oh yeah.
Because she plays the mother and she
makes them oldeR belt and he goes,
why are you gonna?
Make me hold the belt mama,
because you're the oldest.
Hold the belts.
I could shoot this goddamn Maryland
mama's sick.
Oh,
that's right.
This is his best movie by fucking fall.
That was a good movie.
Joe.
I gotta wrap this up.
What are we going to do it how we're
going to kick open the new year?
We didn't lay a bet.
Nothing.
Nothing about fucking John Jones
gusteson.
If he had a better.
You didn't give me a breakdown here that
John Jones versus gustafson.
Yeah,
I'm stuck on both fights.
That's all I want to tell people that I
wouldn't bet me.
I can bet either.
They're both very good.
Matchups,
very good mattress sideboard.
You have to give her an advantage
because she's so much bigger and because
she just doesn't seem to lose.
She's just smashing people.
She's got really,
really good technique and she's super
powerful and she's really big and she's
got a lot of success.
And then amanda is,
is without a doubt the hardest hitting
bantamweight.
She's fucking cool.
SMash her man.
She has a gate camp.
She's long shoulders.
She keeps people in the end,
the punches.
She'll.
She's gonna test sideboard.
You know,
we're going to find out whether or not
she could hurt her and then we find out
if she could hurt her.
This kid get crazy.
who the fuck knows because Amanda Nunez
can't.
If she hurts,
cyborg can get crazy,
but if she can't,
she hits harder than holly.
I think in my humble opinion,
I think holly is a great kicker and
holly is a,
you know,
she's really good at movement and she's
very durable and a holly managed to go
the full distance with cyborg,
you know,
it was a hard fight.
It was a hard fight and she lost that
fight.
Um,
the,
the difference between holly and Amanda
Nunez,
I think it's like one shot power is
better for nunez,
but you know,
holly,
when she fought germane to me,
she,
when she fought jermaine,
she knocked her down.
She knocked her down,
a straight left.
She hurt her,
she heard her a couple times.
She had kicked her.
She hit her with a question Mark kick
and had kicked her and germane to
random.
He is really good,
heavy,
heavy duty moy thai fighter,
but she didn't want to fight cyborg.
Holly did sidebar.
Just the biggest and the best in terms
of like,
you look at our success ratio.
You look at the way she beats girls
down.
She's so powerful,
man,
that amanda is the toughest fight for
our.
This is.
Yeah,
this is.
This is.
If you go back to cyborgs,
fight with gina carano,
gina
carano one point in time was on top of
her on the ground.
She didn't sustain it and she lost the
fight and cyborg eventually smashed her.
But gina had her moments in that fight,
you know,
and uh,
don't think gina was ever the one shot
cracker that amanda is.
However,
cyborg is way better than she was back
then.
But you know,
so was amanda.
Amanda,
you know,
coming off of their cal pennington
fight,
you watched that fight.
She dominated raquel pennington and I
think we're one of the toughest girls in
the division.
She's,
she's a hard woman and she,
she beats a lot of really good fighters
and she,
she gave holly holm all she could handle
and then got a split decision loss to
holly holm in holly's debut in the ufc
and she's fucking good.
And Amanda Nunez handled her.
It was very,
very impressive.
Who scary like dismantling.
She's beating her up.
I was like,
wow.
like she's on another level now as a
champion.
She's gotten even better.
She was always really good.
she was always really dangerous.
But as a champion,
she got even better when she beat ronda
rousey and 48 seconds.
That was the big coming out party.
Like here we are baby.
She's,
she's the best bantam weight ever,
you know,
in terms of her ability to knock girls
out.
Like she's the scariest of all time.
She's the only one.
I mean,
sidebar can't make 1:35.
Amanda nunez can.
She's a legit one.
30 five champion,
you know.
And she's got it down now too.
She can go five rounds.
She can.
She can beat the fuck out of you for
five rounds now.
Totally the interesting.
Listen,
merry christmas.
Merry christmas are family.
You know,
I love you motherfuckers.
Merry christmas to you,
my friend for christmas,
my brother this week.
And uh,
I don't think so.
Not this week,
but we'll see each other soon for sure.
After the afternoon.
Alright.
Thank you everybody much.
Love.
Bye.
Merry christmas.
Happy new year.
Happy hanukkah.
Happy kwanzaa.
Mary.
Everybody.